[музика]
ва самі перші отак ідешперед диш нас а
ми за
тобою Європи
Іна велика країна щоб соі пону свободу
Ми пронесли багато років свою мрію про
ільну державу ідеме на ківаків на
державу ми маємо
право ми маємо
право Україно
ти належиш мені Україно через декілька
літ в бачить велику
країну моя
Україно ти належиш мені Україну через
декілька рі і побачитьли
Україну Моя
[музика]
Україна спеціально
упрся
[музика]
[оплески]
ну
чушь напиши д минуты перерыв поправиться
надо поправить
оборудование слава Україні
слава слава
наці Україна понад усе Україна понад усе
Україна пона
все вітання усі Україні сьогодні ми тут
і цей маршце не просто ми виходимо на
нсь права
і це
машгодні за Я
зрозумів
[музика]
сейчас камера упадт напиши и
будет
ріру
[оплески]
рсь
[музика]
вот под
наклейкоро идём
обратно
ки привітільше таких
жіно всё понял хорошо Сейчас буду туда
[музика]
подня
грубо говоря рух ветеранів
[музика]
украї Коман що земтрима спи
[сміх]
[музика]
та трошки схоже просто і
всею почався стім в почався якщо ви
бачите якщо не бачите мож ту бачи
Та це Київ центр Києва Я не знаю чи є
інтернет чи немає інтернету я так думаю
що інтернету майже нема і чути мене чи
не чути отут десь мікрофончик десьго
можна Героям
слава центр Києва якщо є зв'язок ну
трохи пострімимо
Якщо зв'язка не буде якщо інтернета не
буде Ну то ну така наша ситуація бо
всього на всіх не вистачає всіх дуже
багато всього дуже мало інтернету на
всіх не вистачить Людей просто море там
далі отам зі станції метро Університет
Там просто йде море Людей просто мор те
безліч неможливо порахувати скільки там
людей всі свої всі вітаються всі з з
символикою всі вітають друдрого зі
святом кажуть Слава Україні відповідають
всі такі посміхаються це круто за
можливості
об'їжджайте вулицю бульвар Шевченка
Володимирську давайте трошки що ми
трошки пройдемо отам туди покажемо що
там які там палатки є що там люди є що
тут взагалі відбувається людей дуже
багато
всі патріотично хто вишиванка хто з
прапором справа громад вся
тут палатки тут люди
тут шановні
ветерани чи є інтернет там що пишуть 101
ну це Бачите вже це якесь досягнення
нової влади от як не не похвалити того
Зеленського молодці бачите який інтернет
При Порошенко такого не було оце хо хоче
якесь досягнення я
шткую бачите намети стоять дуже багато
людей тут А ще що хотів сказати дуже
багато лю людей збираються десь Вони
домовились ще я так розумію там вчора
позавчора І стоять люди з плакатами там
деснянські район от що тут Павлоград
наприклад да і Павлоград збирається десь
тут то есть люди приїжджають Різ з
різних міст дуже багато людей підходило
із Одеси і з Харкова і Дніпро і ну всі
кого тут тільки нема всі всі тут взяти
собі взяти собі один прапор можна взяти
прапор я то можна луганському один
прапор видати лично дайте один прапор
лично
Ні не можна Я везьму отакий Бачите я
буду з
прапором візьму прапор бо це
важливо паблату Мені дали прапор по
блату з
такою вудочкою яка чи вона спрацює чи
ні зараз ми його розгорнемо
це круто я вас друзі Всіх вітаю зі
святом для того щоб розуміти що таке
незалежність на жаль на жаль
можливо
Ну як це так от правильно сказати щоб це
було зрозуміло можливо
треба трошки її втратити щоб зрозуміти
навіщо вона потрібна то взагалі як і
Свобода як і незалежність Бо коли ми з
вами в 91 році отримали ту незалежність
А ми і не знали що з нею робити Що це за
незалежність що вона нам дає Чи дає вона
нам хоч щось ми ми не розуміли коли поч
почалася війна 2014 рік це зрозуміло
було що де є незалежність де є право де
є Свобода де є Закон і порядок там є
життя і незалежність вона насамперед і
гарантує вам право закон порядок життя і
це дуже
важливо між хлібом та незалежністю нація
повинна обирати завжди незалежність бо
незалежність вам дарує і свободу і хліб
А якщо вибираєте хліб то згодом
ви втратите і незалежність і свободу І у
вас не буде свого хліба я васіх Вітаю
такі стріми Ну трошки Я похожу зараз
телефоном я вам покажу що відбувається
Так буду знаєте просто відеорегстратор
який вам покаже що Я такі стріми не дуже
люблю сам коли ну просто От вам
показують що відбувається навкри але
якщо Ви залишились сьогодні вдома і ви
не в Києві то Ну трошки трошки
пострімимо походимо я забираю телефон
почитаю ваш чатик глядачі вже тут стоять
тут що глядачі
скажете Слава Україні Слава Україні
слазалежно святом всі пишуть що на вас
дощ лізе І що будемо робити
Нічого сахарні
нічого
страшного а люди пишуть що на Майдані
вже співають Люди в білому щось там вже
там Типу як того як того року Там хтось
там щось там риб читають чи що там риб
читають Да дуже багато людей просто море
море ніхто не може знайти друг
друга дуже цікаво що є інтернет Андрію
де ви Ну а де отут ми бачите це
перехрестя там де багато українських
прапорів там і
ми що
пишуть
в мене робочий день пишуть Ну я не знаю
Можна було б сьогодні
і не прац це на Університеті Так це
університет Что за город Андрей пишт Ну
Торонто звичайно бачите яка діаспора в
Торонто зібралася дут українців Hell H
Торонто да пишуть що це звичайно що
Торонто де б ще можна зібрати таку
кількість людей
унїн безкоштовно хто
хочефоткатись пробле безкоштовно покаж
давайте отак от я зараз так зроблю і
будуть
фотки то фоткатись підходьте будь
ласка дякую Дякую друже
дякуюги можна підходьте будь ласка ди
куди
дивитесьте бульвар вче Дякую кожен день
дивишся
яй
б до
паркуку дякую дякую доб доб ва Дякую за
дякую вам всіх благ
вам
здоров'я зі святом вас дякую вас зі
свято Да будь ласка підходьте без
проблем в прямому ефірі отуди
Передавайте
вітання вітання
кориць кажуть що найкраща якість стрімо
відео і звук це коли отак от просто
вживу спілкуєшся і все будь ласка
фоткаємо хто фоткається давайте
фоткатись оттуди вітання Передавайте о
на ту
камеру можна можна будь ласка
підходьте умовно тут іде колона як
кажуть військові гражданських цивільних
а там попереду є колона військових бо це
ж все-таки знаєте парад
це більше військова тема і зрозуміло що
військові собі окремою як вони кажуть
коробкою зорганізувалися
і вони будуть іти там попереду я якщо
можливо наздужину вам покажу але поки що
буду
тут ще раз хто не дуже зрозумів Привіт
Привіт
Привіт пару слів прямий ефір кажіть що
ви
думаєте 29 років - Це тільки початок
Білорусь ми з тобою
рівняйтесь Дякую Дякую це буде Україна
Ну не знаю така вона в нас Молода
Україна маю на увазі така вона красива
але вже стільки всього знаєте такк на
тілі багато ран але я впевнена що ми всі
не просто подолаємо а настануть у нас і
не просто гарні красиві часи А якщо ми
будемо всі разом будемо її любити
цінувати то ми будемо мати міцну красиву
країну і навам буде Що передати нашим
дітям зі святом усі дякую дякую Дякую
дійсно тут є люди які підтримують і про
Білорусь у мене
запитували що я
думаю я вже казала друзі я була і на
акціях підтримки і дійсно переживаємо що
у них там відбувається і хочемо щоб у
них було так само така ж сама можливість
на їхній День незалежності відчувати той
дух який відчувають люди тут Зараз і
відчувати те що це наша країна на
що
це наше об'єднання ми всі єдині тут хто
зібрався ми відчуваємо ось те
що тільки присутні тут можуть зрозуміти
мене про що я зараз кажу А якщо ви
дивитесь дистанційно зараз нас в ефірі
то
так Слава Україні
Слава
е Якщо ви нас дивитесь дистанційно
хочете підтримати якось то ви маєте таку
можливість будь
ласка поділіться цим прямим ефіром щоб
поки він є Поки він живий поки інтернет
ще працює то щоб більше людей змогли
долучитись і побачити це Натисніть
кнопку поділитись і також поставте
вподобайку цьому відео щоб його Facebook
більше поширив і так його побачить
більше людей
давайте робіть робіть фото Я просто
стрім
веду дякую дякую
Мола
там дякую дозвоте давайте очень
ратруленка просто
шикарна Спасибо за Дякую дякую ще будь
ласка давайте давайте ой ставай до мене
Ходи Ану чекайте я покажу вам цю красуню
дивіться Хто зі мною
фотографуєдивиди Бачили які в мене
красиві підписниці Ага тільки тут такі
зібрались сьогодні вже зі мною
фотографувались красуночки в вишиванках
і і Красені фотографувались такі
маленькі дуже красиві Дітки тут теж
прийшли
всі У кого є маленькі діти з дітьми
легендарна
н дякую дякую супер
канал ой Дивіться це брати
капранови канал тг
Шевченка знаєте
таких
і Вітаю Вітаю Що для вас незалежність що
ви відчуваєте зараз незалежність -
це коли ти можеш приймати рішення коли
ти можеш їх висловлювати висловлювати я
можу немножко ошибки допускати А можна
на російськім з незалежність- это когда
ты чувствуешь что есть правильные вещи
есть неправильные вещи и ты душой
принимаешь решение вот это делать не
буду это плохо а это хорошо и даже если
за Это хорошо будут наказывать Это
хорошо и это нужно делать вот это
независимость Дякую приехали з Харкова
Так ми з дружиною приїхали з з Харкова
на зустріч прапора Вчора ми вас бачили з
Андрієм А вчора ви були ой Вчора було
дуже класно
вчора легендарні наш
Дякую вчора так Вітаю О бачите і Дніпро
і Харків всі тут всі тут зібрались всю
Україну зібрали в одному місці Вітаю
Вітаю добрий день Вчора ми були на дні
прапора на Майдані Незалежності і там
розгортали прапор єдності той найбільший
прапор там 33 м який возили по всіх
містах в Україні Це було дуже ефектно у
мене на сторінці є цей прямий ефір ви
можете подивити
ви можете подивитись дуже красиво вийшло
і так було емоційно класно Подивіться
будь ласка цей прямий ефір теж І вам
сподобається ще готуємось Ще чекаємо
Коман до коли всі будемо йти А який у
нас буде маршрут якщо ще хтось не доїхав
і хоче ще встигнути долучитись то ми
зустрічались біля метро
Університет до вас найближче Я не знаю
яке буде як нас наздогнати і наша
фінальна точка - це Європейська площа це
якщо йти повз Кияни мене зрозуміють повз
Майдан Незалежності туди прямо-прямо
прямо і там виходить що
вулиця Інститутська Щоб я правильно
зараз сказала напевно Інститутська і там
є таке коло там ще
прапори НАТО там сцена Ну ви все це
побачите тобто Якщо ви будете тут ви
побачите
що повз майдан Незалежності прямо-прямо
і ви прийдете туди куди
треба передайте Привіт Це прямий ефір
побажання
ми вас пізнали вітаємо всіх захисників
зі святом і Дякуємо їм за то що боронять
нашу країну велика дяка Слава Україні
Героям слава вам дяка Ви дуже мужня
жінка ви все говорите їм що думаєте
відкритим текстом і ми за вас вообще
гарою кулаки Дякую ви У нас в одному
ряду Федина ви Маруся звіробій одна
лінійка во
більше нас було щоб люди прозрівали і
бачили що ми за єдину вільну Україну без
всяких там вказівок непонятно від яких
сусідів самі гарні вільні і беззелені і
Дякуємо нашим воякам Дякую які нам дали
можливість отут зібратися і вшанувати їх
Дякуємо прямому за його хорошу роботу
Дякую бачите ось волонтери справа громад
допомагають орієнтувати всіх людей Дякую
волонтерам Е що теж Візьміть Прямо будь
ласка
агащо
дякую і да дяка нашим воїнам за те що ми
можемо сьогодні святкувати незалежність
України що вона у нас є всім воїнам
велика дяка слава Героям слава
[музика]
дякую ще друзі є така проблема дуже
парить на дощ зараз буде дощ там небо
трохи
дуже парить буде дощ напевно але ми це
витримаємо це не проблема абсолютно для
нас коли ви чуєте що люди аплодують вони
алодують вім які проходять повз
дивіться он там військові Ідуть вони
йдуть вперед колони
бачитеку і люди їм аплодують і дякують
за наш захист і насправді це настільки
емоційно що просто пробирає до мурах і
до сліз серйозно коли люди дякують
воїнам І коли вони дять повз їм
аплодують і просто ну це це хоч якось
вони хочуть Так виразити свою підтримку
нашим військовим які нас захищають це
прекрасно волонтери роздають маски
бачите у кого немає маски роздають
багато роздали масок
багато Так що все у нас я стараюсь так
подалі від людей триматись щоби в масці
дуже важко ще говорити в
мікрофон трошки поведу стрім а там може
одягну але дотримується хто може
соціальної дистанції це все особиста
відповідальність
кожного понад
усекраїна понад усе
українас Добрий день слава слава
слава
[музика]
Слава
украї Вітаю
вас цікаво що там буде буде відбуватись
на Майдані тому що Минулого року Влада
співала гімни читала реп ота дівчина
пам'ятаєте з тарілкою на
голові вона читала реп під час виконання
гімну тут ми такого собі ніколи в житті
не дозволимо бо це зневага до державного
гімну ці люди такого собі не
дозволять ще покажу Ось там така цікава
штука маскувальна
сітка що ж там написано зараз
[музика]
прочитаю маскувальні сітки група
мармелад
цікаво волонтерська група ластівки А це
колона
волонтерів Коротше кажучи тут окремо
колона волонтерів як правильно казати не
колона Вибачте коробка це
називається дивіться Ось так видно Я
трошки згори
стала тут є коробка військових вона в
самому
початку є коробка волонтерів і є коробка
просто людей патріотів які прийшли сюди
теж
долучитись а пишуть що там зараз ще
гірше ніж реп під час виконання гімну
дивилась і вимкнула ну Дивіться якщо
буде інтернет і ми з вами дійдемо туди
то я вам покажу що там тому що ми ж якби
будемо проходити повз напевно Чи я не
знаю як це буде відбуватись який у нас
буде маршрут але якби По ідеї він має
пролягати якраз через Майдан
Незалежності тому якщо не відключиться в
мене інтернет на телефоні Бо коли багато
людей збираються Отак то дуже погано
працює Інтернет і я зможу вам показати
що
там
ломался вас вітаю вітаю перше полк
луганського радіо
аматеор пару слів для людей прямий ефір
так Всіх вітаю з святом День
незалежності прийшов з
сім'єю своїм сином також блогер перший
полк луганського давненько правда не
виходив А на стрімах як
радіоаматор всім вітання дякую
дякую прохання маленька ви коли відете
стрими трохи далі мікрофон і Андрію у
вас перенавантаження по звуку Я просто
намагаюсь робити так щоб мене було чутно
і
максимально аце маленька справа громад
бачите який в нього капелюх класнийже
Привіт Що скажеш про
Україну не знаю що сказати засоромився
камери Я розумію це воно трохи лякаюче
для
дітей зна Це наша країна треба було
сказати соромиться Сьогодні в нас що
день народження день народження України
сьогодні кажи Слава Україні Слава
Україні Ой дякую клас соромиться дітки
соромляться
камери це тут якщо дорослі вже Вибачте
соромляться камери то дітки Звісно що
будуть соромитись камери я і сама коли
починала робити відео то трохи теж так
якось ніякого перед камерою але в
принципі я не дуже соромлюсь просто
трохи ставало Ніяково трошки зажимаєшся
знаєте так і коли якщо я запитую у людей
щось то не всі зможуть відповісти одразу
бо ну воно трохи лякаюче що ти в стрімі
і Але я нормально а дітям Ух ти дивісь
ще прапор такий
величезний голуб
миру можна вас автограф
напрапор Давайте давайте Тоді я вас
попрошу ви потримайте познімайте тільки
я ж йому попишу футболку Напевно а я
буду таку тримати ми розтягнемо ну
Дивіться ви ще оце потримайте А я сама
все зроблю
добре
славатт
відеоставили Дякуємо дякую дякую гарного
дня вам
тримайте Ось і таке буває Вітаю
Вітаю
вставайте Дякую це наш друзі Так це ефір
можете щось пару слів сказати Слава
Україні Слава Україні Героям слава Дякую
дивіться трохи небо затягує Ну хоча б
немає такого сонця знаєте бо дуже
парило сонце Прям таке світило яскраве
яскраве Ну бо такі світлі люди зібрались
звісно стільки людей світлих і буде
сонце
світити дітки в
вишиванках що скажеш про
Україну
соромиться соромиться це це нормально я
питала щойно хлопчик теж
засоромився діти Вони
соромляться героям
слава
я
хвилиноч Та давайте з вами хтось
сфотографує сфотографуйте нас так це
Одеська Команда оде А що це у вас це у
вас що медаль якась що це жертовність і
любов до України так Ага це волонтерська
нагорода православної цпцу угу угу Дякую
за
інформаціюме мені треба то просто
зробити з Марією Давайте давайте з
Марією тільки щоб я гарно виглядала
маску Зніміть якщо можна Та требарід
отак гарна
посмішка так один
кадр три кадри все вийшло дякую дякую
Це я вже трохи просуваюсь поки стоїмо
встигну повернутись назад просуваємось
трошки вперед покажу дивіться які
красиві люди в сукнях яскравих жінки в
вишиванках чоловіки в вишиванках в
віночках
жінки справа громад бачите волонтери
допомагають зорієнтуватись Хто де
знаходиться О я дійшла до колони
військових зараз вам покажу ой
Пропустіть
Пропустіть тут є такий банер бачите
лежністю не
жартують з незалежністю не
жартують а тут несуть цей прапор єдності
який ми вчора підписували якщо ви бачили
Ось
він ось він 33 м друзі величезний чи це
не він Чи це він це прапор єдності так
так величезний а он там він його зібрали
Харків Миколаєв
запоріжжякунці украї ці
україкра Так це друзі це прапор єдності
його провезли по 24х містах і тут 33 ме
і скрізь люди підписували передавали
вітання побажання і он там він такий
великий його трошки зібрали ще бо коли
колона розтягнеться то будуть іти
маленькая Спасибо вам большое дякую
дякую работу и за все за ВС Мы вас очень
люби дякую
дякую
А ось ми дійшли до
військових добрий день шановна Давайте я
можу так під час трансляції хочу
привітати всі Я просто всім показую що
зі мною
фоткаються
бгів4 кожен
На
пару слів тоді в ефірі
скажіть
требатмати а про що
казать Ну по-перше я Всіх вітаю зі
святом дуже дуже важливий для нашого
суспільства день і Хотілось би щоб вся
наша багатомільйонна країна вчу відчула
що ми одна нація Одна країна Ми повинні
бути Разом прагнені до перемоги
і Вибачте я трохи
хвилююсь українцям Побажаю ще бути не
зглавними сильними і духом і здоровям і
так далі сьогодні південь України
миколаївщина в Київі представлена і
Миколаїв - це є Україна ми завжди були
форпостом півдня тому всім передаємо
вітання всім патріотам всім хто сьогодні
є частиною української нації для тих це
свято дуже важ тому наші вітання всім
всім патріотам ветеранам військовим і ТМ
особливо Хто знаходиться на сході
України тому що на жаль вони не можуть
бути сьогодні присутні тут Тому хлопці
всім вам вітання ті хто на сході нас
захищають Слава
україніту яку тож нехай це величне свято
вляє в кожного з нас гор за весь
український народ
маія трошки по-другому виглядаєте на вас
підписано по-іншому це
до слова запрошується благочинний
Білоцерківського району православної
церкви України настоятель церкви Покрова
Божої матері Микола
[оплески]
Гопайнич сучасна Білоцерківська громада
Слава Ісусу
Христу Вітаю всіх нас нашу квітучу і
незалежну Україну з цим великим
святом але жити в незалежній Україні ще
не означає бути вільною
людиною тому що протягом більше як 20
років з 91го по 2014 рік ми бачили що
хоча б на словах ми були
незалежними але в реальному житті нас
продовжував наш східний сусід
поневолювати Сьогодні ми пригадуємо ті
події ясловськоїго
Коли Україна склала домовленість із
нашим східним сусідом і саме від тієї
миті яка стала початком відліку великої
біди поневолення і
рабства найкращі сини покладали своє
життя у боротьбі за найвищий прояв божої
любові яким він нагородив вінець свого
творіння
волею Сьогодні ми бачимо як в Україні
починає відроджуватися і українська мова
і українська церква і українська
армія бачимо як діти починають
виховуватися саме в любові до своєї
України коли кожний їхній навчальний
день розпочинається із гімну
України Ми пригадуємо сьогодні ту
Криваву історію якою
поневолися покарати український народ от
щойно заговорили чи тягне стрім чи ні Я
там підішла на одразу ж стрім перервався
тому друзі йду назад поки там є ще
зв'язок трошки там ще пострімимо з вами
але далі буду йти поки якби не
перервиться трансляція сама я її
вимикати звісно не
буду
сяємо
сяє це все за покликом ви мене
фотографуєте я в ефірі можете сказати
щось в ефірі що ви
відчуваєте бутицька громадська
активістка справи громад дуже такі
емоційні враження тому що дуже багато
людей і ми за незалежну суверенну
Україну Слава Україні Героям слава
справа громад такі активні я от до кого
не підходжу тут всі справа громад це
дуже круто насправді багато людей
об'єднала справа громад Тому зараз буде
Секундочка
реклами Секундочка буде реклами Хто хоче
долучитись до справи громад Я вам раджу
є сторінка в Facebook справа громад і
пишеться як чується і подивіться вам
сподобається можете стати
активістом Молодіжка тут як тут
Молодіжка Вітаю з складанням присяги і
так можна передати пару слів прямий ефір
Всіх вітаю зі святом свято незалежності
України це дуже важливо для нас я так
вважаю як українець як громадянин це
дуже круто треба треба розуміти
святкувати бо незалежність вона треба
цінити її
цінувативол класні долучайтесь до
Молодіжки теж солідарна
молодь солідарна молодь - це круто
бачите справа громади солідарна молодь
разом Всі
стоять пару слів Всіх вітаю з
святом Да дякую мене звати Богдана я
вітаю всю Україну з святом тому що це
важливо для нас мию незалежність
вибирювали сторіччями потрібно цінувати
тому що за теперішнє покоління не
розуміє наскільки це ціною нам в далося
і треба це цінити тому що в сусідній
державі люди не можуть так вийти і бути
вільними і волі Воля - це супер ми
можемо вийти сказати свою думку і це є
незалежність та що нам подарували батьки
наші діди і наші хлопці Захисники які
виборюють зараз нам на передовій А ми
Стараємося її виборювати тут у тилу
Дякую всім святом Дякую дуже гарні
слова ось банер із незалежністюють
ми не дозволимо жартувати з нашою
[музика]
незалежністю
[оплески]
45 коробка люди котрі підтримують нашу
армію представники
поверни живим ля
[оплески]
лясихоло свява і
вас Вітаю Вітаю пару слів прямий ефір
Хто
хоче Оксана буд
ла
48 замикають наш марш представники
справи громад та всі охочі всі наші
грома на захисників
України ну
да
починається
рух просуваємось потрошку вперед зараз
завернемо на
бульвармо
швання і далі по команді будемо
розпочинати наш матч захисників України
шановна
шановні глядачі будь ласкаді Та
[оплески]
тротуариз
всі
вирушили потихеньку потихеньку
вируішаємо корпус університету ви можете
побачити хто в Києві не був ото червона
така
стіна це червоний корпустягне інтернет я
вам покажу з того боку а то є жовтий
корпус з того боку он там через
дорогу е філологічний здається корпус
якщо я правильно
згадала
молодці
[музика]
молодці Душу тіло
ми жем за
нашу А можна я вам
подарую Я добре
[музика]
Героям слава Ви краще ці квіти знаєте де
залишіть
будемо герої Небесної Сотні їм залишити
Дякую Від мене і від вас і від нас ну же
лися вас обняти пашаленка потрясна дуже
А вас дивлюся навіть останній завжди і
ви настільки іронічно знаєте що я вас
дивилася останнє коли ви казали як
багато справ зробив Зеленський і
поштарем попрацював а лишилася ще
каналізація прибирання і
все уда дякую вам а квіти Там залишите
Так це буде класноке
проханняягайте масочки Якщо у вас є і
дотримуєтесь з дистанції та наче ж вже
вирушали але ще стоїмо трошки трошки
будемо
рухатись може там геть аж там пішла вже
колонна і вони просто йдуть розтягуються
Бо коли колона йде то зазвичай спочатку
трошки поспішають а потім позаду люди
трошки повільно йдуть і того воно так
нерівномірно
А що ж там на Майдані Незалежності
відбувається от Мені цікаво що там на
Майдані Незалежності зараз є там якісь
святкування немає що
там Ну вони ніби трошки починали йти але
чомусь зупинились Я думаю що скоро вже
підуть бо вже ж і час
вже
1054 тамтвори там військові там дуже
воних плотно вони набиті і там не можна
пройти як ну Я намагалася але не змогла
і там інтернет ще не працює того я не
пішла там спочатку йде колона військових
а далі йдуть волонтери там і всі всі всі
інші з
Одеси Ні він з
Одеси А ви з'єдналися з Южного
Це просто нереальна кількість справжніх
українців Дякую я нен з оде напревеликий
жаль так би хотілось зараз на
море як там в Одесі є Одеса напишіть в
коментарях є Одеса хтось з Одеси
дивиться
[музика]
насла украї Слава Україні украї сва
[оплески]
нації
Україна
Україна Україна
що дуже давно вас шукала і чекала там
про Миколі Джері є питання будемо робити
це кіно Так слухайте ще дивіться історія
кримських татар готується книга
аудіокнига ізріна ви про неї вже чули Да
вона російською видана була в 13-му році
але целінуримо має авторські права але
на жаль ці сть років Тихо світи народи
на ний фонд подавалися гроші закінчилися
400 чимось Люми набрали Але ми не
пройшли я погрош все одно не відступаємо
будемо робити і у нас значить дивіться
медіоперсони будуть читати шматки як
арабці ну тобто аудіокнига буде записана
ну кимось зз одним голосів але будемо
або на АТР або ролики робити в Ютубі ми
вже перекладаємо волонтери вже це
роблять і будемо зачитувати шматки і
якби вас Ну якщо ви погоджуєтесь
зачитайте шматок якийсь української
А це
наіла зайдете велика ідеяні мені мої всі
контакти мені можна писати Я читаю ми
просто знаєте що побачитися серпень
по-перше дуже дуже хороша пропозиція
Дякую вам добре але ви розповсюдж доб
або хоча б просто промовте айер
муждабаєв в цьому проекті ви його
знаєтерфан
кудусов У нас тоже підтримка Кримський
Дім ну коро вселямов це
голов який надав Там право контент
створити зрозуміли
баі багато
ма ви на
змію отак стоїш собі А тобі пропонують
озвучити аудіокнигу це приємно тут мав
пройти якийсь інший
захід тому я хотів би щоб ми
показали ще раз нагадую Хто не зрозумів
чому люди плескають і кому вони
плескають нашим захисникам коли
проходять повз захисникі в формі
наші військові то вони їм аплодують і
дякують Таким чином підтримують ой
Подивіться яка прикольна дівчина хто
прийшов на Мар
України клас класна маска
дуже
вітаюлю Одеса так Одразу видно
здалеку а Славутич так Я
показувала Слава
Україні
Слава
году Добрий
день Да це
я
давайте
секундочку я потом скажу підпиться вона
дуже
це хто дивиться блогерів наших україн
той
знати
всізнаю нас не сфотографують сфотографу
так же ж
незручно бачу тут багато нас і луганськи
і
полтавакраї
держах окупатвїх повників
сва
дякуюкра шановні учасники Маш велико
цей
млн що сказати сказати що що Людей
просто я не знаю скільки вже людей Вони
не вміщаються трошки вже втрамбовується
ця колона бо там вже скінчилась вулиця і
вже люди отак от уже вже вже і там
протилежну сторону вулиці вже окупували
я не знаю що там сьогодні робить Влада
люди підходять кажуть що там щось там
вже виступає десь е та Вірка Сердючка
там хоп-хоп-хоп і оце от бачите ну як
можна порівняти от от це людей
патріотично налаштованих і там якась
Вірка срдючка Я не знаю що про це
сказати як як це коментувати Я не знаю
якщо ви в Києві не знаєте Чи сидити вам
там сидіти дома на дивані чи вийти
виходьте людей дуже багато буде концерт
на європейській площі там буде авінта
козаксистem
широкилан незалежність бо це таке свято
знаєте раніше Та чесно кажучи раніше не
зовсім ми його відчували Ну я кажу про
себе про своїх друзів ну це був такий
додатковий вихідний Чесно кажучи можна
було поїхати на море там знаєте Ну типу
там длинные выхоідные це так от якось
називалось А сьогодні ти відчуваєш що
незалежність Якщо воно є то незалежність
вам дає свободу дає волю і дає закон і
порядок і ваші права вони захищені бо
якщо є незалежність якщо незалежністі
нема сьогодні будемо Ну можна можна жити
як там наприклад окупований Крим як
Ростовська область як ворониш розумієте
яка там незалежність людей там є Буряти
є окремо Дагестан є чеченці є татари є
якути вони живуть в них немає ні своєї
культури ні своїх законів Вони живуть
так як їм вказує Москва Я вважаю що на
2020 рік такі імперії як Московська вони
повинні зникнути щоб їх взагалі не було
і щоб сусіди цієї країни жили вільно і
свободно Я вас вітаю з цим святом це ну
це найголовніше свято нашої країни це
день народження країни але ми з вами
раніше може не зовсім це відчували а
сьогодні відчумаємо відчуваємо всім
серцем бачите скільки людей вони кричать
Дякуємо коли проходять пов учасники
війни з Росією військові і це дуже
важливо і для них це важливо і для нас і
я думаю що для всієї країни що можна
сказати тут окрім того що Слава Україні
- це не просто слова і не просто вітання
типу Привіт привіт Слава Україні геро
Слава це слова які мають великий сенс я
вітаю всіх глядачів зі святом Слава
Україні Слава
Дякую це був Андрій
Луганський
шановні учасники ваш Нагадую що якщо у
вас єні ма Чи все таки будь ласка
проктуйтесь
ними
людинівава дуже
важливожею Я маю надію що цей стрім хоч
трошки передає вам те що тут
відбувається
так ніби Я ваші очі зараз і ви дивитесь
як те що я бачу Ну те що Бачу я і
дивитесь ви на відео я так намагаюсь
показувати все що
довкола ще раз Нагадую що підтримати цей
стрім можна тим що ви поділитесь ним у
себе на сторінці або десь в групах
киньте Хай інші
дивляться поставити вподобайку Ні ну у
себе на сторінці це обов'язково треба
поділитись А як же
ж пишуть про якусь жовто-блакитну сцену
під ногами це те що там на Майдані зараз
це там у них сцена в кольори нашого
прапора
розписано це ж паплюження символіки Я ще
не бачила але якщо так як ви пишете то
це
жахливо
Вітаю Привіт ленці Ленка сьогодні не
прийшла цікаво ті глядачі які не
розуміють Ой
зараз
ті
вже пішла дивіться
[музика]
отак всі
вирушили
потихеньку потихеньку вирішаємо корпус
університету ви можете побачити хто в
Києві не був ото червона така стіна
це червоний корпус утягний інтернет я
вам покажу з того боку а то є жовтий
корпус з того боку он там через
дорогу
там філологічний здається корпус якщо я
правильно
згадала
і
покаже що
мицая козацькогоро
лушу тіло ми
пожи за
нашу і покаже А можна
подарую Я добре
я сва Ви краще що ви думаєте про це це
цікаво Ленка Це мій персонаж я бачу
Ленка - Це мій другий персонаж вона так
і шукається в пошуку Ленка через є
українську Подивіться вам
сподобається
В мене
трошки дроти
спали
подач там може німне там работать надо Я
понял Мне просто сказали тут стоять
[музика]
понию Давайте може я
туда закину или лучше не
надо
в принципе можешь тут где-то
пристроиться но я тоже боюсь
этого
га
тут капитально будет звук да идти отсюда
или не Да Капец надо
какстоять Я маю
ты Ну да Ну
посмотрим
если бы не было музыки можно было бы
отсюда прикольно включиться типа ты тут
сидишь с микрофоном такая ну
да
[музика]
уяви свій улюблений
контент шановні учасники Марсу Захисники
України давайте оми підтримуємо один
одного поки мвають
Ати
дякує
[оплески]
куємо
дякуємо дякуємо
якуємо якуємо
[оплески]
ятуємояємо сгодні
дення нашої любої України на кону полину
багато крові
століттями ми вали і закар
століттямивали кращі сі чини за те що
берегти нашу незалежність іщо поті Саме
цей день день нашої нежало Незалежності
Слава Україні
ро слава Слава Насті
ворогам Україна до на усе Україна до на
усе
нормально не сильно громко
[музика]
нормально друзі і невеличка об'ява перед
тим як ми будемо починати
н Відродження захи Ників України
запрошую вас на благодійний вечір до дня
незалежності України 27 числа 19:00 на
вднк деятий павільйон це благодійна
акція котра допомагає врятувати здоров'я
наших поранених побратимів на підтримки
наших друзів Сполучених Штатів
волонтерів українців на цьому заході
будуть виступати ЗК sст і інші Іже
класні українські рти
будь ласка приходьте і підтримайте наших
поронених захисників Дякую Вам слава
Україні героям
слава ну що друзіщо прити вже
перекрити це
означає що ми розпочинаємо матч
захисників України 2020
коськи
Слава
украї Україна
го Україна го Україна
[оплески]
[музика]
відео
[оплески]
нави
шов мимо і
[оплески]
[музика]
дивлюсь Слава Україні еро слава слава
наці Смерть ворогам Україна понад усе
Україна понад усе Україна понад усе
[музика]
[оплески]
єє
[музика]
бра
Дава
[музика]
[сміх]
оперного театру як бачимо зараз ц
може ты бы сюда как-то села
типа давай можедой давай я руку
подам
так хоть час запргують потому что потом
раз
[музика]
движение
могли бы отсюда хотя я не
знаю кого
чернякова не мы могли бы Но потом я не
знаю запрыгнуть в принципе
мы если бы они быстро оперативно нас
включили то вообще
супер не мы могли бы Но потом я не знаю
запрыгнуть в принципе
мы если бы они быстро оперативно нас
включили то вообще
Су
може
[музика]
Я думаю я сда
сгенерато
главноеб
масажик
ма
да и
тпленька и
тпленька Ну что следим тогда за
обстановкой
українасе
Україна
[музика]
дякую
нагадувати що нашій
країніває
війна там
Влада каже що ніхто не загинув Це добре
Звичайно Це добре але жя Чи маєте звідти
от зараз контакти і якісь стравні дані я
не маю справніх даних це я так то що то
що кажу то я кажу я не ю справніх
даних Але ж прошду це не головне головне
повернути наші нашу Землю нашу територію
до яку ми поклали багато життів багато
хлопців поля це про це треба пам'ятати і
нікого не забувати на жаль ішня Влада
грається
[музика]
йналє партій
на Марс ветеранів Михайло Доброго дня
Доброго дня Скажіть прийшли на куду
ветеранів Так чому вирішили долучитися
до голонки з незалежністю не жартую ну я
є член європейської
солідарності мої побратими ідуть в
загальній колоні це батальйон імені
генерала кольчицького я як їхній
представник парламенті йду відповідно з
європейською солідарністю яка веде
колону е е всіх небайдужих хто
відноситься до європейської солідарності
Хто готовий підтримати цю політичну си
дуже важливо хочу зауважити що та
ветеранів марші захисників він є
понадпартійним тобто тут немає партійної
символіки тут прапори оскільки святкумо
День незалежності але так чи інакше
сьогодні ставлю всім запитання які
виклики на 29-й рік Незалежності має
України чи дійсно з нашою незалежністі
Зараз повертується ми бачимо що
теперішня Влада заграє
повністю з Російською Федерацією з
країною агресором вдивляючись в очі
Путіну і дивлячись що там є
якийсь мир на їхню думку і я вважаю що
це якраз іде до того що теперішня Влада
готова здати Україну готова здати її
суверенітет незалежні тому є дуже
великий ризик цьому загроза дуже велика
є цьому Я думаю що ці ветерани ці всі
люди небайдужі які сьогодні зібралися
цього не добить чи вже мали змогу почути
привітання президента України чи зможемо
його так коротенько обговорити чи ще не
мали часу і готувалися Я цього не
відслідковував тому що сьогодні я бачив
дуже багато побратимих з якими я
пересікався на лінії розмежування на
передовій пізніше як волонтер коли я
їздив на передову тому дуже багато було
спілкування дуже багато ми згадували від
14-го року по 19-й і тому я не мав
счатку просто дивитися привітання з
кажіть наскільки от важливо ветеранам
волонтерам військовим в цей день от ма
знаєте зараз в нас ідуть коробочки вони
крокують паралельно люди їм аплодують
наскільки це важливо відчувати шану для
вас оскільки ну завдяки вам ми дійсно
можемо святкувати 29й День незалежності
в
Україні не на всій території На жаль але
на більшості під мирним небом в столиці
може збиратися така велучезна кількість
людей наскільки важливо відчувати шану
ці це дуже важливо тому що всі ті хто є
на передовій якраз захищають мирне
населення тих хто е працює тут на мирній
території Хто допомагає армії і е
вдячність яхю чути це дуже е потрібно
для ветеранів для військових це дуже
потрібно і в попередні роки коли був
парад це якраз і було потрібно для
військових щоб показати Мирному
населенню міць нашої армії А зараз
дійсно ветерани виходять що
почути оці Оплески від мирного населення
оцю вдячність їхню за пророблену роботу
за їхній труд за їхні Добре дякую пане
михайле і ще останє питання вже буду
бовас кадати за що любите Україну за все
за то що вона просто Україна за її мову
за її землі за її нарід за її культуру
за все дякую Дуже очасно дякую А ми
вачимо Володимир очковані Доброго дня до
Доброго дня Скажіть будь ласка що ви
відчуваєте зараз тут на ході ветеранів
чи вперше чи були догорів був минулого
року також і знаєте Я гордий того що тут
зібралися ті які захищали а допомагали
захищати Україну починаючи від 14-го
року ми також вирішили доєднатися до
коропки незалежністі на жар
чому щось не жартують тому що справді це
є те що зараз є кончени і на жаль так
сталося що у нас політична влада зараз в
країні є длі які дуже заважливо
ставляться до героїв неважливо
ставляться до тих здобутків які Україна
отримала за останні пть років кривавих
здобутків і тому для нас дуже болить
коли хтось намагається цеглинки
державності розбирати і ними торгувати
ми цього не дозволимо І тому ми тут дуже
вам величезно дякую ще раз покажу що
отже очільник колони Михайло заброський
вже на місці І вже Воро саме ця колона
рушатиме натомість показумо що
відбувається давайте трошечки швиденько
щоб розуміли наші глядачі по картинці
кількість людей яка крокує прямо зараз
з парку Шевченко саме біля метро
Університет от крокуєть коробочками
цивілізовано до Майдану Незалежності ми
ж будемо іти з ними аби ви були в курсі
ще раз всі з незалежністю нашою слами до
студії
колеги мийдемо з ними аби ви були з
нами
[музика]
[оплески]
Хорошо мы в полек поле Ну иди
[музика]
да
натаємо ру здобутки
проклистоє перед нашою
державою здобутки на обли на лице як то
кажтьди скільки народу тут за
[музика]
вийшли Саме через те що здобутки требаро
боронити і самий головніша збута що на А
ви на ви сьогодні вирішили рукувати в
коробці ці правильно
я тільки що йшов кримськию
коробкою Які відчуття оті кримською
коробку по центру столиці Україна дуже
знаєте дуже потужно на цього року
коробка Я не знаю якмилого присні але
доволі потужна коробка і як людай люди
як
ть
колице зворуш скажіть за що любите нашу
наньку України за що за те що вона є за
те що вона в серці за те що ненька
Україна - це це любов Господь Бог є
любов Україна є любов і любов до України
- Це найбільше відчуття яке можеселитися
в
серці Я не знаю А за що
в що воно
єяку вам величезно зі святом вас зараз
підемо до Олександра рчинобумо
[музика]
щеватися
пане Олександре можна їм вас трошки що
не дають пройти сьогодні ще раз не дають
кажу пройтись давайте трошечки зійдемо
Якщо не проти буквально трошки щоб
трошки
заважало
я дано старту почалося півгодини тому
Може трошки більше і ще всі коробки не
змогли пройти до хрещати про що це
говорить така єдність говорить що сотні
тисяч українців патріотів сьогодні
хочуть йти хрещатикам де вже два роки
поспіль не проводиться військовий парад
тобто Влада просто боїться його
проводити нема про що звітувати але
сьогоднішній марш сьогоднішні скажемо
так єднання патріотів демонстрація того
що в Україні є сили які здатні захистити
нашу незалежність в Україні є сили які
здатні не дати ні зовнішнім ні
внутрішнім ворогам знищити Україну і Я
переконаний що все бачить не тільки
Україна все бачить весь світ
Незалежності не жартуйть так називається
кокробка Я так розумію з якою ви будете
увати Що вам дійсно здається що на 29-й
рік незалежності України на сьомий рік
війни у нас жартують з незалежністю ви
знаєте на жаль не професіоналізм
ватність я би так навіть сказав
зеленість у всіх сенсах цього слова
чинної влади сьогодні стає загрозою для
Незалежності тому що ілетантизм руйнує
економіку руйнує обороноздатність е ми
бачимо Навіть є загроза здоров'ю нації і
в цих умовах відбувається і підтримка
п'ятої колони і договореніки з
російським агресором все це безумовно є
серйозною проблемою і проти цього
сьогодні виступають люди і проти цього
сьогодні цей марш незважаючи на марш на
кількість людей можна сказати що
українці можуть дати відбір безумовно
безумовно е
Я даже не знаю скільки зараз людей тобто
понад 100 000 - це 100% І це не всі ще
мали можливість приїхати сьогодні до
Києва тому що єх карантинні заж в
багатьох регіонах але все одно це
демонстрація сили демонстрація єдності
демонстрація того що українці нікому не
дадуть жартувати з незалежністі Дякую
оне останнє питання за що Любити Україну
простае дуже питання але знаєте дуже
багато тористу ви знаєте А за що любиш
свою мати за що любиш свого батька Тому
це Відповідь одна Ми Українці це наша
мати і ми продемонстрували що здатнії
захистити Дякую Олександре за
[музика]
свято до
брома
подождику я
[музика]
[оплески]
ребят
[музика]
так нормально
буде дощ починається але кажу то на
щастя дощі на кажу кажу що дощ
починається але кажу ве щастя моє
питання наступне чому на 29-й рік
Незалежності на номерів війни Ми чуємо
Нева що незалежніжер чи дійсно з нею
зараз можна взагалі таке
довати взагалі з Незалежності жартувати
Не можна те що зараз робить чинна Влада
во не вкладається ні в якій раз і цього
року як і минулого ми прийшли щоб
показати що ми є в нас не буде ходіти
неможливо нас посадити неможливо ми
готові давати опір
рива Скажіть будь ласка за
щоказатині за служкількижливорано
і облиски від україв які при подивитися
на ма Скільки вам це важливо почути шанс
оскільки нажально завдяки справді
точніше завдяки вам мож рукувати отак от
мені більше важли ливо щоб аплодували
решті хлопців в основному це мої
солдатам впершу чергу будь-якому
війському звісно приємно відчувати шану
українців і ми
маємо так само будь-який офіцер має
віддати шану свому солдату оскільки
солдата ми ніяки командири так А чому
все таки вирішили дойдати саме до ціє
коро по-перше тут люди рідні мені не
тільки за бови м а також за політичним
вподобанням тут є прихильники
європейсько солідарності справи громад
тут є бойові як командири так і бійці
які пройшли війну з початку 14-го року
Супер дякую за свята і дякую вам за цей
день незалежності
дяку также А може в них а їм теж треба
на
що то робиш
Віталі може з вами також Доброго дня мож
доброго супер як атмосфера як
настрійжай вжай кілю прошу це вражає
кількість людей Чесно кажучи навіть поки
не можу осягнути скільки їх насправді і
чи більше чи менше ніж минулого року
суб'єктивне відчуття що більше і
набагато більше тому що от скільки
коробки йдуть і спускаються внизу до
бесарабки А я бачу що там Людей менше не
стає і ми розуміємо що там ще десь
приблизно така ж кількість Тому це добре
багато коробок Сьогодні багато людей Вже
ввечері скажемо підсумок яка кількість
взяла участь у марші ветеранів але так
чи інакше ви доєднались до коробки з
незалежністю не жартують чому саме Так
по-перше
це ключове гасло яке будеться донести до
банкової і це натяг на те що все те що
тут відбувається
попри формат без політичних прохорів це
насправді політика найголовніше політика
українських патріотів захист державності
і з такими речами жартувати Не можна і я
поважаю людей які говорять про це прямо
а ви говорите про це прямо безумовно Ну
і ми також говоримо про це прямо і
ветерани які стали за цим банером
говорять прямо і ти цивільні які стоять
далі туди в бік метро крищатик також не
соромляться своїх поглядів що з такими
речами жартувати Не треба бо інакше
Навіщо нам тоді країха олесію чи вже
вдалося почути привітання президента
України Володимира Зеленського Чи можете
ви Ну от речі які вас здивували приємно
і неприємно ящо вдалося зти ну з точки
зору журналіста Я можливо неправильний
речі скажу бо там слід було б бути в
контексті подій які розвиваються але
даруйте Я не хочу увати Зеленським собі
День незалежності тому я не дивився на
цей не знаю і не хочу знати що це було
таккі сьогодні виклидки їть перед
Україну на 29-й рік нашої Незалежності А
ви тільки що його згадали цей головний
вибр це Зеленський тому що люди які
ведуть капітулянтську політику люди які
визнають що вони не мають стратегічного
мислення і не можуть думати про те що
буде навіть не завтра А післязавтра люди
які угробили армію люди які здали наші
позиції на міжнародній арені це і є
головний виклик причому Нам усім для
кого незалежність - це не просто слово
це не жар можете ви назвати Це як
загарвання з
незалежністю це не загравання в мене
таке враження що вони не розуміють що
таке незалежність а свідомо чи
Несвідомо Я перепрошую в мене нок Я маю
відповіід це дуже важливо доб роз тоді
просто вітає зі святом зає переюю
це
що
перекуч дождевик естьж чний планр
[музика]
Да давай
секун
[музика]
іщо
можна м
сфоткать знаю осторожно только у меня
тут
трансляция
[музика]
[оплески]
лай
ребятки продавали вот эту версиюпере на
модемо за 45000 я посмотрел а те которые
мелкий вот этот один интернет wi-fi и
USB моде за где-то баксов 200 мо ну
разные есть это просто именно такая
Телевизионная версия там ещё эти цими
занимается У меня tвиision studдиio отка
вот студии этот tisionстудия которая
камера вот это мова
два кирпича 2, по Сейчас я хочу взялать
про комвертор хочу попрошки покидовать
потому что я столкнулся с тем что
реймрей разные количество кадров падает
всё ИЖ не ви Можно
пожалуйста я выш как быно в помещении
всё а тут надо школе делать Ну тут тоже
скорость сложная очень оно типа падает
из-за того что много людей А у нас не
в извиняюсь можете
пожалуйста у меня трансляция трансляция
у не можете барабан
[музика]
поставить
шаге
рі жия
ріли нашарея
мали тури Святу
[музика]
Слав нера за ранку і
горею щи
ша
[музика]
ver
[сміх]
[оплески]
куємо
дякуємо
[оплески]
момомомо
дякуємо
дякуємо коро буде
спробувати
ска чому нам ли виходити на де
залежності на такі великі слені
Маш я вам скажу що два роки назад коли
був відмінений парад коли Люди могли
побачити що
вкладають кошти держава хто їх захищає
завдяки кому існуєть суверенітет України
незалежність України Це було потрібно
коли Зеленський це відмінив люди почали
приїжджати за свої кошти е Спілкуючись з
побратимами вони говорять ми готові
навіть скинутися щоб техніка проїхала
щоб показати всім громаді що Які в нас
збройні сили є Тому це потрібно і
найперше от зараз треба почути ветеранам
вдячність від людей від мирного
населення від тих кого Вони захищають
Тому це дуже важливо як і для військових
так і
длявяз обов'язково хто ще раз говохто
каува ски
жра готові са снутися
[музика]
якщое е премію треба роздавати Окрім
цього А напарат має бути чітко за
заложені кошти бюджет на проведення
параду
щорічно Кікі
людей дуже багато людей Мені дуже
приємно Я не вражений Я дуже приємно Як
то каже задоволений що така маса
приїхала я буквально вчоравернувся з
львівщинином І взагалі навіщо йому був
Майдан навіщо йому боротьба а він хотів
жити в нормальній правовій ветерані
олися ще там тобто проводити на місцях
ці заходи тому Якби ще вони приїхали тут
було би набагато більше тому знаючи що
столиці Це номер один проведення такого
парадуго маршу ветеранів Я вдячний всім
що приїхали сюда показати що нас дуже
велика кількість і вдячний всім тим хто
зараз в регіонах проводять відповідно
такі самі мітинги марші підтримуючи оцей
рух марш ветеранів показуючи що ніякому
зеленському не вдасться приховати цей
рух не вдасться принизити нашу армії
наші збройні сили Нічого ми йому не
дасть офіс президента проводить свій
альтернативний с ходу ветеранів Як
думаєте чому вони не долучилися до
численного маршу
захисни по-перше Я навіть не
відслідковував Що вже таке проводиться а
найголовніше що я вам скажу як він може
доєднатися людина яка не служила ва а
людина яка відпусила від
армії стояти поряч з хлопцями дівчатами
які пройшли горнилу війни які знають що
такі бойове Братство побравтини по
сестри Ну як він буде очолювати отаку
худу а там приказали хлопцям Я не кажу
що вони не військові чи ще щось просто
їм приказали офіцери вони стоять в
коробках і роблять як весь час картинку
для Зеленського може не з першого здубля
Може з другого з третього як в 95му
кварталі вони привикли це робити Так
вони і роблять відбулися так само
урочистості і за участі президента але
кажуть військови не допустили навіть
були посилені заходи безпеки як вважаєте
чому не долучився са президент до
ного Мара ви
знаєте коли його обрали тільки
президентом і Перша його поїздка в мін
оборони його охорона забрала зброю
військових тобто
головнокомандуючий не довіряє своєму
війську от на це все
питання
Дякую що там Тебе питали що ти вже
наговор пані Мар Розкажіть будь ласка
чому все-таки ви долучилися сьогодні
знаємо що ви людина військова проте
все-таки зранку в понеділок в святковий
день вирішили сюди прийти Чому тому що
зустріч з побратимами по-перше це святе
коли ми разом зустрічаємося це лікує від
дуже
багатьох неприємних емоцій які
доводиться в тилу спостерігати коли ти
борешся за перемогу
а Твоя влада зараз не бореться за
перемогу вона хоче просто капітулювати Я
бачу це так і багато моїх побратимів теж
так це бачить
це і так знаєте важко прийти з війни не
досягнув результаті і це не дає спокійно
жити потім в тилу але коли ми збираємось
разом іми один одного
підтримуємо чому взяли з собою а
насправді я не взяла з собою взагалі
квітів Це ті квіти які подарували люди
коли я походила коробки на знак
підтримки на знак солідарності зокрема з
коробкою ріфмастера Кузьменко і Яни
дугаль коробкою солідарності з Кримом
Свободи політв'язня так що
Це
просто вияв якогось позитиву від людей
але я особисто хочу ці квіти залишити
біля місця загибелі Сергія Нігояна щоби
там було більше квітів щоби люди частіше
згадували за що він віддав життя А чому
самепіля того міста прошу чому саме Біля
того місця вирішили по-перше Сергій був
перший по-друге так як він читав
Шевченка і його заповіт це думаю
вкарбоване в серці кожного з українців
по-третє він був за походженням
вірменином і взагалі навіщо му був
Майдан навіщоому боротьба а він хотів
жити в нормальній правовій державі де є
честь і гідність де є можливості
розвитку зрештою це все ті цінності за
яким ми почали наш бішість років тому
сьогодні маємо просто ще раз і ще раз
про це все згадувати І тим паче тоді
буде зрозуміло що з незалежністю не
жартують незалежність не дається просто
так незалежність - це величезний дар
який ми маємо шанувати і сите життя про
яке нам розказують окремі середовища
воно є можливе тільки в незалежній
державі яке дає право на реалізацію
кожному громадянину власне моє це
питання полягало в тому вийдете в
коробці з незалежністі не жартуєть моя
назва питала дуже багато військових які
вирішили крокувати цією коробкою тепер у
вас як народного депутат як українке
зокрема чому вирішили рокувати саме цієї
коропи сьогодні Ну насправді Тому що це
є найголовніше гасло сьогодні коли до
влади дориваються церкачі
маніпулятори як кажуть про хвост є таке
от гарне слово не нашою мовою то вони
починають загравати жартувати е
маніпулювати викручувати питання
Незалежності тим самим незалежність
нівелюючи як таку з незалежністю не
жартують Тим паче що сьогодні вже в
сучасних реаліях за неї було пролито
стільки крові віддано стільки життів і
коли хтось від нашого імені хоче
домовитися з агресором впавший на коліна
перед ним Ми будемо не тільки нагадувати
ми будемо робити все щоб захистити
незалежність України незалежність
кожного громадянина і гідність людини в
Українській державі які сьогодні перед
Україною на 29-й рік нашої Незалежності
стоять буклики які це перше залишитися в
часопросторі як самодостатня держава
тому що якщо ми будемо черговою черговим
сателітом Московської Федерації то ні
Про яку незалежність ми не зможемо
говорити другий момент - це є
усвідомлення того що немає політиків
кращих гірших тих яких нам показують по
телебаченні є люди які мають Україну в
серці які мають чисть гідність і які
вміють і можуть щось робити А є ті які
зневажують абсолютно все і бавляться з
долями кожного з нас третій момент - Це
нам треба захистити наші кордони нам
треба захистити наше майбутнє а задля
цього не можна категорично
важувати армії не можна її
дискредитовувати і деморалізовувати і
тут варто пам'ятати от саме в цьому
пункті армійському що чим сильніша армія
тим менше до нас лізуть тим менше буде
ймовірність великої війни а отже більше
людей зможуть жити мирно і спокійно ще
один виклик це як ми скажемо так
розвернемо Україну з напрямку
какаяразніться на напрямок самодостатній
це є все-таки доведення до ття реформи
судової сфери томущо що ми бачимо що
саме через судові органи через судову
гілку влади А так само їм скажемо так
паралельними дпрри ГПУ і так дальше саме
влада яка намагається узурбувати все
вона здійснює репресії проти людей гі не
угоди і саме з Судової гілки влади має
початися встановлення правового режиму в
державі де є закон понад усе і всі
дотримуються закону незалежно на якому
там вершечку чи низу ти знаходиш
і напевне п'ятим моментом виклик це
є усвідомлення своєї самодостатності
возбуття комплексу меншовартості тому що
нам постійно от зараз особливо багато
намагається розказати що українська мова
не така тут історія неправильна а тут
герої якісь не такі а отут ви не то так
зробили а тут не туди ми вибороли
Україну 29 років тому ми захистили
Україну зберегли її 6 років тому сьогод
согодні ми розбудовуємо українське в
Україні яке завжди було пригноблене і ми
нарешті маємо цим пишатися от моє просто
питання за що Любити
Україну не за що її просто треба любити
Тому що вона наша А тут треба ставити
питання А що ми можемо для неї зробити
щоби вона стала такою В якій би ми
хотіли жити Україна - це ми всі це
Україна це всім небайдужі люди Україна -
це дієві люди Україна в якіх просто
Україна понад усе украна - це те що ми
сьогодні бачимо такий великомасштабний
марш який навіть не знає щоб неберхати
людям в ефірі яка ж кількість люде всеки
за Ну ми були на минулорічному марші і в
мене враження що цьогоріч набагато
більше людей набагато більше людей тому
що забагато знову намагалися сказати що
нас не існує що ми ніхто а вже деякі
московськоприхвосні обзивають наших
героїв рагулями якимись там недолату
зробленими і так дальше і оці всі люди
вийшли ли показати що вони є тими ким є
українцями яки не баййдуже Супер дякую
зі святом вас зі
святом українці так нам заважають це
зробити заважають Колонізатори які далі
продовжують намвати Ми переможемо і
заможними теж будемо будемо Якщо будемо
так як поляки в НАТО і в Європейському
Союзі остаточно затвердимо свій вибір і
остаточно забудемо про минуле як про
Імперію так і про минулу спадщину ну
цінностей того часу па Ніна а ч ви
поводжуєтесь можливо якісь економічні
Вис мені взагалі здається що от слово
незалежність тільки зараз більшість
людей відчуває і глибоко розуміє що
означає це слово ще 10 років назад мені
здавалось що це якась формальність
відбулася тобто Україна ось є незалежною
державою зараз
відчуття про те що цю незалежність треба
зберегти найвищі найбільші і тому така
велика кількість людей які не залишились
вдома байдужими а прийшли сюди А чому з
незалежністю не жартують тому що це
зараз Самий актуальний лозунг який може
бути в нашій країні незалежність ми
тільки зараз починаємо відчувати що
означає це слово маємо боротися тепер
щодня для того щоб зберегти справжню
незалежність і щодо розбудови держави
держава в нас насправді ще дуже молода
ми тільки починаємо розуміти як її
відбудовувати і саме який економічний
устрій ми маємо будувати тому мені
здається по-перше всі мають об'єднано
розуміти яким крилом Країна має рухатися
і вибудовувати свою державу але
вибудовувати її ми можемо тільки коли
вона буде не залеж почули ми вже
привіітання президента України
Володимира Зеленського софіїська Польща
Чи можемо ми його обговорити же ще не
мало часу
сьогоднімію правильного вислову а скажу
вам що з одної сторони розумієте
получається що це круто Коли військова
техніка а з другої сторони це втрата
просто фінансів ресурсів можна краще
допомогти потім відходиш вже починається
маленькі містечка вони в усіх країнах
майже однакові якщо є Мери з головами на
плечах то вони вибудовують його от мають
такий погляд количуть про європейськи чи
прозахід а там де у нас ну таке взагалі
змінюється люди без особливого
бачення Одесі поїхатидат Кош ро держави
Але ти вражаєш ти лати що вони кошти ащо
не сервісу не має
сервіс коли саміїжаємо
і такрадуєся
ко що
людинанувинута вона
бачилати стенькі
місця відношення
до культура Мені дуже було знаю так
незвично одесчусвіті всди в світі кава
шла на
промінад
балонні балони газо стоять у таблиці що
відроблють повернуться
достояці готели стояв автомобіль проріза
колесо
розвернули а прорізани колесо Це ж ця
історія що вони ізають колесо А зараз
цій сучасній машини воно ж не спускає
відразу тебе починає рухти десь на трасі
вониють
ко і вони тебе доганяють допомогу от
вибирають машини хують і ви побачите ба
а меніі таких зразу це все розгадав
говориці можете включити відеокамеру
коли порізали голосо Ну десь дві години
назад ми йшли виходили
ми
відразуї і не чекали
закінчення с більшсів Тому може ми так
потихеньку приреждіми дойдемо до
то громаського суспільства яке зможе
дійсно змінювати і птримувати цісь
результати с Як думаєте окрім об'єднання
яка іще отака мета ідея
отакогольного мау
ні
капітуляція ні
капітуляції дивіться дуже багато можна
зустріти сьогодні різних мов але
ее Таке відношення от дуже багато котини
що ее тікипита для того щоб звернув
увагу президент зверну а ті люди котрі
е котрі впливають на цю позицію чому
Тому що ми маємо іншу позицію Ми не
хочемо ее якись лалени перед ворогом Ми
хочемо оттримати Україну неже і Україну
щоброказати та державність я яка має це
системні змінице насамперед системми
зміни маю
і розумієте Ні какуляції це такий
загальний термін дуже багато можна чо на
ну дуже багато чого можна сказати
розповісти але особисто мене це не
капітуляція хлопці об'єднувались
під має бути один якийсь напрямок чи
може їх може бути знаєте як розност
декілька але загальними мій загальний
настрій це ні капітуляція хлопці
об'єднались
і продовжуємо перетвоювати в Україну вку
державу
дянську з правами де закон працює один
для всіх де дуже багато кращих моментів
у житті чим те зараз що ми маємо і те з
чим ми боремося як системне це ворог
який у нас є Ну якось так але це не
означає щось така окрема моя позиція
затаєте дуже багато людей саме
лати А яка ваша мета приходи сьогодні
ваці А ви вважаєте що є зараз загроза
спітуляції Я вважаю що е загроза
капітуляції дуже гарне питання ее Так є
загроза в тому що дуже негарні люди е
якимось чином потрапили якимось чином
потрапили в верхівку влади і дійсно є
загроза дійсно капітуляція але це не
буде виглядати як ми підніма ла це дуже
такий
ее це тей шлях потрібно пройти і ми з
одєї сторони укладємо цей шлях е вони зі
своєї сторони щось роблять на для своєї
мети але дійсно є віддаються ее
розумієте
віддаються навіть не накази а робляться
такі дії які е-е
нецінюють дуже багато чого наприклад
наприклад зовнішня політика
нашого командующо Я не хочу ее якщо люди
дивляться якось відчувають повини самі
мають вже знати які приклади вже
наведені в українській історії які
зробив наш Ломан
і це Ну дуже багато речей я можна казати
просто зараз я вам скажу не хочу е ну в
цей день саме не то що ви еспресити А
пояснюю чому саме але якщо людина
розуміє якщо людина читає дивиться то це
що це очевид це як вважаєте чи
допоможуть Отакі акції достукатися до
влади зокрема до
прода Ну на мою думку ці акції не на не
для того щоб в першу чергуто влада а для
людей які ще якось мають сумні до кого
приєднатися бо розумі що та красиво
знаєте ее Ну от на мою думку потрібно
людям дивитися що ті військови ко
захищали боронили суверенітет України її
державність вони нікуди не поділися вони
є і потрібно якщо ну є якісь
там бажання змінювати будь ласка Ми Тіто
будемо змінювати це баж не тільки е до
людей і до влади яка Ну демократичним
том була обрана у нас і ми ми маємо
тільки так само об'єднання потрішечки
залишаючи в нормативно-правовій базі
зміну і так далі але нам потріб для цех
голосів потріб щоб бачили що люди є хто
хоче зміни є ті хто буде ці зміни
отримувати утримувати саме утримувати
якщо сування закону ну дуже багато
роботи потрібно і нам до речі потрібні
люди з цивільні котрі розуміються
наприклад на южтенденції розуміється на
е ну дуже багато те нестате дуже багато
Є над чим працювати Да і залюки запрошує
людей які дійсно патріоти Україна які
просто хочуть жити в нормальному
цивілізованому суспільстві будь ласка
Приєднуйтесь до військових прите до тих
людей що вже якось зробили
е якісь кроки для збереження України
цілосно ну зараз в мине є цілосноми але
взагалі виглядають як до справи І щось
ви бачу у вас військові нагороди можете
розказати детальніше як виїхав Даша ее
Та ніяк Приїхав з роботи в той час мені
каже прозпішись там щось дали я
подивився а потім воно якось так
і я Ну так кажу що приїхали з роботи і
кажуть Там іди розпишись там ворот не
дав Я розписав году добре
а якісь
там Тобто ви на фронті були Я так
розумію а
бачили в вас на війну на свої очі можете
розказати наскільки як це які
відчуття я Вам краще розповім який
відчутя Коли ти повертаєшся і
зустрічаєшся з тими людьми Котрі з
різних причин не хочуть чути не хочуть
знати Та які відчуття Ну ти повернувся
додому раз рік і людикі ще не не зробили
сво вибір які вони
хочутьнтники наші в літак вірвав от я
знайомилася з цими родинами з цих
хлопців і Я була рада сьогодні побачити
їх
е з
портретамиших героїв але все-таки з
теплим відчуттям
е пам'яті І мені би хотілося
навіка усвідомлення їх жертви по суті це
так тому що це жертовність і всі ці
мамочки дружини батьки діти вони це
усвідомлюють мені хотілось щоб бінш
українські громадяни знали самі цієї
Незалежності і я дуже рада що сьогодні я
тут Де по-справжньому ти відчуваєш ціну
незалежність можна жартувати з
незалежністі от прошу щоб ви мені дали
відповідь на це запитання під Оплески
яки Ми чуємо що наші ветерани наші бійці
вони крокуються а проле не дуже приємно
чути да як люди люди стоять крокують
кричать Слава і Дякую Ну наскільки це
важливо чути нашим військовим
обов'язково Тому що вони це відчуття
подяки Це відчуття ее мобілізації і
мотивації далі боротися коли це ще й з
дітьми і люди вони почувають свою
причетність свою відповідальність до цих
людей тому що ее Я знаю що так підходили
і казали мені дякую за позицію Я вважаю
що в мене просто адекватна позиція
нормальної здорової людининічого
дякувати не треба я більше дякувала їм
за те Вони сказали вам ми я каже бо в
мене так все
добре виходить і говорити і можливість
щось робити тільки тому що ви я є бо
інакше не було б вас не було б нас
справді завдяки військовим нашим
ветеранам можемо сьогодні на 29-й день
народження нашої держави можемо вийти
так в центрі Києва і пройти величезним
маршм це важливо і це цінно А моє
наступне питання чи жартують з
незалежністі чи можна це допускати І
взагалі чи бачите ви якісь ну такі події
що от вас можуть наштовхнути на таку
думку ні я думаю що є певні сакральні
дати які не оговорюються в здоровому
суспільстві з приводу якоїсь сатири з
приводу
кування з приводу знецінення цього свята
і те є і покладена за нього не тільки
сьогоднішньою війною а багатьма
століттями
викошуванням Еліт викошуванням
носіїв Ну не будемо знову нагадувати
українцям в котри яка жертва Україна
давала для то щоб ця державність
відбулась Отже я ну для мене це якось
Ниц невідповідально ну ви ж не жартуєте
з мами Яка б вона у вас не була ви ж не
жартуєте своєї хати яка б вона у вас там
була ви не жартуєте
з місця вулиці дому де вони народилися
яким би вони не були ви можете мило
побачити якісь певні усвяткуванні казуси
Ну так завжди бувають якісь речі які
відбуваються паралельно але це несвідома
річ це це не те що ви це це провокуєте
культивуєте і тому коли ви готуєтися
пожартувати таким святом Мені здається
що подумати треба на такими речами Хто
ви і ви тут живете і Чи маєте ви
моральне право це тепер такки остання
два легких нібито на перший погляд
запитання за що ви любите нашу державу
якою хочете її бачити ще за 29 років Я
люблю землю люблю державу отцу яка зараз
змагається за свою
державу яку я хочу бачити Ну я хочу
бачити зрілою а не такою інфантильною
можливо Мені не вистачає зрілості в бі
більшості громадян тому що останнім
часом мене дивують певні Якісь прояви
українофобії скептизму щодо державності
знецінення певних якихось речей які
досягалися дуже довго в мене наприклад є
певні моральні орієнтири моральні
особистості які цю державу представляють
і вміють тримати диспути за кордоном І
це родити мене наприклад мені здається
що ці люди складають інтелектуальну
вартість вартість це Повірте я не маю
себе я Я вчусь у них ще можливо до 70
дорости до якоїсь такоїсь іності але
мені не хочеться щоб до цього не
усвідомлела політична і бізнесова еліта
і вони були в авангарді розуму інтелекту
і е
притомності ці що таке Україна і який ну
тобто в яку яку вкладаються вони візію
цієї країни от а решта Звичайно все
підтягається ми Україна різна вона і в
під'їздах вона і в і на кафедрах
Але мені здається що не треба залазити в
під'їзд літі яка повинна думати над
кафедрою і над бу майбутнім будучими
поколіннями і майбутнім Україною а от
під'їзд залиште будь ласка він сам
підтягнеться якісний тим хто виробляє
для під'їзда правда Я думаю що еліта
бізнесова еліта інтелектуальна і
політична вона повинна все-таки стати
над уже
цим 29 років час наста Дякую святом вас
Дякую
якучасстоі стоять
[музика]
стоюм
[оплески]
[музика]
ки
оророро
[музика]
дякую
Алі іду
[музика]
іду
корона з голови
упала
що powerбанк твой надо
отдатья волновала чтоб те пабанк отдать
заряд
нормальный зарядила
телефонна
пришла
трело подивитися що там в ефірі ну
мабуть є у
віконці Ну віконці ми Да
трошки
може делаетьм панорамку туда показать
немного
яраз співає
покаже
що Душу тіло ми
Поло за нашу
сбо
Слава Україні геро
Слава
Путін
повертаєся не забарись як
кажуть
Подожди подожди по А Ладно Ладно
всё яраз Ну да чуть-чуть
но
Крим -це Україна Крим - це Україна Крим
- це Україна
м
[оплески]
Україна
[музика]
[оплески]
ina
жеж
[музика]
кують
[оплески]
представники
кадр
а кадр
[оплески]
е
люгей люгей люгей целюгей целюгей
люгейлю
[оплески]
дівчата
льшеці у
вас ручки не
боліликуєкуємо
дякуємо
[оплески]
як вони не сішли
Да Ну то Если бы ты ше блокнотами
ромечило то всх
поубивало з В мене просто
якствка получается подходт Я смотрю ряд
Уже вот здесь ГТО я реально понимаю
что покал не он мне показывает что типа
это что типа в сторонку Я говорю не у
нас типа
Ех это не вот так ну да ну ми так
підійшли І добре що я
писала
[музика]
us
прикольно
[музика]
увана
[оплески]
вона
те скажіть чи дійсно ви вчуваєте зараз
на 29й рік Незалежності що мають якісь
такі
нище з Незалежності так я відчуваю що
нас щораз кожного разу стає щораз
більше Влада Я думаю що цей крок
зрозуміласкільки вони не розрахолику
велику кількість людей Вони там якісь
свої Маі
привозтьлюде спеці з реіоні звоять
насильно Дякую вам нашле От бачите
просто що розуміли що багато глядачів І
немлюєся годинами кчати і казати дяку
нашим
захисникамраз Захисники починають ро
залеж бачите яка
ль Доброго дня зідки Ви ітки
приїхалильвісь область Львівська область
А де войвале а Маріуполь бачи бе
залежності на жртую чи дійсно відчувати
що зараз відбуваться якісь жарти з
незалежно 29-й рікй рік вільний
жар нашу країну захищати і захищати від
ї зелені зараз припішла
допадиіть а не втумилися чекати поки
ваша коробка зможе рушити з
місцявились трошки але це говори про
Що Що Що є то є
то я хочуу до людей ставлю питання і Ми
продовжуємо говорити
[музика]
Так ви думаєте що
с я вопро
атання ви мене почуєте нам довелося
чекати щоб кода ружала май 2 по годи про
що це говорить говорить що сотні тисяч
патріотів вийшли сьогодні на хрещати і
демонструють що в Україні є сили які
захистять і незалежність і свободу
України
нарешті пане михале от саме очільник
цієї колони цієї коробки я запитаню що
та вас чекало щоб ваша коробка під ваш
голови не змогла рушити майже 2 по
години про що це говорить сьогодні
говорить в першу зібрались люди
військові дисципліновані які добре
знають що таке дисципліна добре знають
що таке
організація що ви відчуваєте виєте
Дивіться яка кількість людей
вамтуєть скільки це важливо чути для вас
вчуваю велику
відчуваю велику шану нашого народу своїм
[музика]
кам очільни коло коробки незалежніст і
Діно майже 2 по години до
чекати аби ми могли рушити
від Петро рища Петро університет
перепрошує а
університету як такого от бачи така
величезна колона зараз будемо йти І
пробувати спілкуватися з народом що вони
відчуваєть скажіть Доброго дня в
наспрями прямого каналу що
відчуваєтеку дякую велику за підтримку
знаєте ми приїхали з вівчи відстоювати
нашу незалежність ми розуміємо що
боротьба і досі
триває незалежністьчи не жартують
називається коробка якою ви пробуєте
скажіть чи дійсно ви зачуваєте зараз на
29-й рік Незалежності що мають якісь
такі
ірнище з незалежністі за Україну са ви
даєте вшановуєте тате подяку нашим
військовам
так як атмосфера вам що
відчуваєтеркуючими центром столиці Що ви
чуваєте сьогодні Ну в мене зараз такий
заряд
ом я бачу масу людей що нас Україна вся
за
Україну скажіть не втомились чекати поки
ваша коробка матиме змогу рушити з місця
Дуже довго чекали втомилися але як
подумати як наші військові ідущ і сніг і
мороз так що треба терпіти А якщо йде
якийсь конлик ше з палочкою з поранини
взагалі думаюш Ти повинен це зробити
так дійсно бачили сьогодні такий кадр як
наші хлопці наші чоловіки
втративши ціною свого власного здоров'я
приходять с одно на марші крокують від з
неце вартує багато Супер дякую за святом
вас кращи прямий Так звісно нас сьогодні
також вітають тому що прямого сьогодні
такого свята так чинакше бачите оця
коробка ще триває несуть 33метровий сях
нагадаю його вчора ввечері на Майдані
Незалежності розгорнули був на
розгортанні прапорапяти президент
України і от сьогодні центральними
вулицями столиці його пронесуть ну і так
бачи що вже люди дуть співать на чолі
Дина очолює як я бачу Ну я прямий ефір
яквно що ви як зав в перших ляда Що
відчуваєте вже як рушились мі я відчуваю
гордість за наш український народ Я
відчуваю гордість за свою украї що
насправді емоції переповнюють але я
шаюся що я
українкакраїна дійсно єдина ми всі різні
ми приїхали з різних взагалі точки захід
сід північ південь чого не всі тут
приїхали особливість в тому що ми не є
різні всі українці вони є українці а
різними відміне відносє ті хто Україну
не любить тому я дуже тішуся що на цьому
марші захисників дійсно об'єднана Вся
Україна і показує що ми єдиним кулаком
учасі потреби можемо дати ворого від
яких ще коробках Вам сьогодні вдалося
побувати Я знаю що ви приходили
підтримувати Юлію Кузьменко Яну дугорі
чи дійсно прийшли підтримати а там дуже
багато людей прийшло підтримати і
правозахисників і просто небайдужих
людей так само чудова коробка Криму так
само абсолютно чудова коробка фонду
повернися живим зрештою кожно коробка
кожної області кожної організації
структури батальйону які долучилися вони
є неймовірні і шкода що одночасно не
можна йти у них всіх бо ці всі люди чи
на фронті чи в волонтерській діяльності
чи в громадській діяльності вони шість
років боронять Україну і зрештою завдяки
таким як оці всі люди які сьогодні йдуть
Україна є і Україна буде Софі скажіть от
зважаючи на кількість людей які прийшли
подивитися на марш не зважаючи на ту
масштабну кількість чоловіків жінок
дітей навіть які долучалися що вже можна
в нас країні ще дос ртувати з
незалежніст мож з
незалежніромі
украї
Україну вогий
я Україну будемо стоять а
ворогили соцмережах що люди ветерани
добровольці всі охочі собі влаштували сі
звичайно такий марш марш Якого в нас
нема вже другого року парад точніше от А
зараз я бачу ще дуже багато
політиків і депутатів давайте
посилкумися з ними попитаємо Артур
герасма Доброго дня Доброго дня
співголова фракції європейської
солідарні свм ва зі святом Україна зі
святом українці пане Артур дивіться
майже 2 з по години довелося чекати
принайні ці Роб це все висвітлювали про
що говорить що така величезна кількість
лю хочу взяти участь у матчі ветеранів
наскільки це є позитивним фактором
сьогодні ви знаєте це було приємне
очікування тому що підходили вітали зі
святом сотні людей тисячі людей я
спілкувався майже з представниками з
усіх областей України і Це було
неймовірно і те що сьогодні така
кількість людей в центрі Києва показує
що в нас єдина Україна в нас суверенна
наша велика
держава воно має бути дуже серйозним
прикладом того що ніхто в цій країні не
може здавати наш суверенітет не може
здавати нашу землю і не може здавати
нашу
українуредини Крим - це Україна Крим це
Україна і ви бачите зараз ідуть актемчий
гос ідуть представники кримсьх татар
представники межлісу і ми їм дуже за це
вдячні була окрема коробка сьогодні
знакувала представників кримських натер
тут в Україні але ви долучились до
коробкип з з незалежністі нежартую чому
саме на це пав ваш вибір і чи можна
взагалі вести мову про жарти з
незалежністі на
29-й рік нашого народження України як
такої держави незалежної Ну і на шостий
рік війни в країні йде війна ви
правильно сказали гинуть наші хлопці і
дівчата на фронті і не дивлячись на те
що сьогодні нам намагаються сказати що
нібито є перемир'я ну слухайте навіть
під час цього перемір'я ми бачимо як
проривається інформація про обстріли то
там то там на лінії фронту
є речі з якими не те що жартувати Не
можна це є речі які є святими для кожної
людини це Як твоя сім'я це як твоя маті
це як твої діти і от незалежність це є
свята річ для українців давайте не
забувати вже більше 10 000 загинули під
час цієї війни і пам'ять цих людей
пам'ять тих чиї портрети сьогодні несуть
мами і в цій коробці і в інших коробках
ми маємо зробити все щоб жарти нинішньої
влади яка на жаль не розуміє цього не
завершилися чимось поганим бо з
незалежністю не жартує не жартує світься
останнє дуже просте питання за що Ви
любите
Україну Я люблю Україну за те що я тут
народився за те що тут рідна земля яка
дає силу кожному і в моїй сім'ї і моїм
дітям і кожному кого я бачу і тут і
кожному українцю хто сьогодні є і в
Україні і за її кордоном Дякую пане
артуре ще раз зі святом вас вітаю тому
що це свято для всіх нас дякую вас також
зі святом ваш канал зі святом всього вам
найкращого Дуже дякую дуже приємно що
прямий сьогодні вітають тому що Т роки
ми в ефірі три роки розповідаємо
найважливіші події для вас Так чинакше
дякую величезно але па Артур затронив
тему що ідуть багато матисей з
фотографіями своїх синів родичів які
загинули на фронціі на сході України
загинули за нашу з вами свободу от я
бачила де жінки Давайте підійдемо
спробуємо неї спитати що вона відчуває
сьогодні в такому марші ветеранів зараз
прошумо за назручності друзі Це прямий
ефір тому Доброго дня чишва бачи що у
вас є
цева це ваш син давайте познаймите Мене
звати Олена вас я Світлана це Габорак
Олег
Васильович Він загинув в 15-му році 18
років
що ви
відчуваєтели що от чуте Дякую областки
чи вчухає вас біль от скіки попри п
ні біль не минає просто з цим полем
просто ну учишся жити можеш вже про це
говорити А так сільни медаль Зумі за що
ваш син вдав своє
життя він у своєму віці думав що такий
як він І взагалі всі повинні бути там і
повинні відстоювати свою країну тому він
був впевнений що це не це Не
даром Ну я вам дякую як мамі і дякую вам
за вашого сина так Ну як бачите дійсно
сьогодні було так багато матерів які
приходять вони не можуть зрувати сїм
полячк почули що вільно щухає А так чи
інакше наша коробка рухається Центрум
столиці вже майже за ходимоми серевській
площі і Бачите як багато української
символіки багато українських
синьо-жовтих сятів зауваж що цей марш
захисників України він є понадпартійним
тобто сьогодні ви не побачите жодну
партійну сиболіку політичну сиболіку ні
лише українські рапори українські грби
вишиванки дуже багато дівчат жінок
сьогодні втягають нашу національний одяг
час незалежні ще будемо свткувати
далізнайтеже наш незалежність сказали що
тут є Артем с теж хочу з ним дуже сильно
поспілкуватися пане артеме Доброго дня в
нас ями ефір Вітаю вас зі святом Ну тому
що для вас всіх це є свято Скажіть теж
чекали дуже довго на
початок коли коробка вашаможе рухати Що
відчуваєте взагалі сьогодні крокуючи
центру столиці це кожний
шах крок до того
щоби відчувати що обов'язково українці
визволять ри от тут це
дуже чуєш це і те що сьгодні ввоєму
виступи казав Зеленський що матері
більше у них немає сліз
це дуже велика помилка тому що в Криму
кожного дня когось чіпляють когось
крадуть когось в тюрми кидають і матері
там плачуть і будуть плакати до тих пір
поки Крим буде не визволений від ворога
Росії це він як президент він це
должен чітко для себе розуміти Я так
розумію ви чули про мову президента
привітання президента сьгодні чи
достатньо вам було вні питання Криму чи
достатньо На порядку денному привітання
президент згадав Крим наш півострв Він
згадав раніше він плутав завжди да А
цього разу він згадав але
розумієте коли ти от тут ти розумієш що
Крим Україна Тому що тут люди які будуть
боротись будуть зі зброєю боротись за
самостійність за незалежність держави за
Крим против ворога для тих які тут для
них чітко є разница де ворог А де
патріоти де є люди які будуть боротись і
стояти віддавая свої свою своє життя за
незалежність держави бачили навіть що є
сьогодні окрема коробка
маєст тут в Києві пробували тосими
поспілкуватись що кажуть люди
ми тут взагалі окремо я думають це така
символіка Але Крим тут всюду всюду і
всюду
люди кричать гасла Крим - це Україна і
всі це гасло багатотисячні
е от ції колонії його
його від від серця
скажіть А за що Ви любите
Україну
Україна Україна - це держава наша
Україна
україн передм Це українці Які такі
ж вони своє життя віддадуть за свою
незалежність і ми ми коли кажемо ми
українцігелю гелю гелю
ге бачу віктоя пані Віктор Вітаю вас зі
святом Скажіть які ви бачите сьогодні
здобутки України за 29 років нашо
незалежнознате я
дужеї
що році реально народилася та Україна
доросла Україна
доро
тікидо Слава
нації
лекий одна
єдина Україна одна єдина Соборна Україна
одна єдина Соборна Україна одна єдина
Соборна
Україна одна єдина Соборна Україна одна
єдина Соборна
Україна Насправді все
українське напевно від страху напевно
від страху людей да Напевно від страху
людей Герої не вмирають
вмирають зється що це найбільший страх
сьогодні Володимира Зеленського бачити
оцих людей на вулиці які ніколи не
вийдуть за ним і у підтримку його
ініціативи але вони виходять за свою
країну за свою незалежність за дорослу
незалежність і за Власне кажучи те щоби
ми були все-таки європейськи це от
європейський Майдан почав в 14-му році
сьогодні ми бачимо таке дуже логічне
продовження що це просто Ну Це
фантастично це справді фантастична
енергія тому що люди вміють
самоорганізовуватися як на Майдані в
14му році Так і точно зараз да люди
організувалися самі прийшли сказали Нам
не треба влади для того щоб зробити наш
свій паради святом зо Супер дякую
незалежністі у вас тому що це для нас А
я ж
хочу Ми вийшли до Майдану Незалежності
просто Подивіться Перепрошую вас
Подивіться яка величезна кількість людей
кує центром столиці і ця да триває вже
понад три години тут линають патріотичні
пісні патріотичні вигуки
нема вми відчуття свя Слава
україніг
с різх
[оплески]
ку маршраіце є пот політична організація
тут може знатися хто
заправило що все було чемно все було
дотримано бачите кількістьже пройшла і
жодного не
кинутоєте
[музика]
F
[сміх]
[музика]
краї
Україна
Україна Україна
чудова
диція незалежності України
чається маршем захисників України з
усієї України прибувають ветерани
волонтери Захисники
України йдуть хрища йдуть Центральною
вулицею
столиці ми бачимо наскільки багато людей
[музика]
[сміх]
по
[музика]
украї
[сміх]
[музика]
станнім Я думаю надо спривать з машини
оіце мо
[музика]
[сміх]
що про руемва буде Пока
[музика]
подойдува
ка с
[музика]
хоть
asik
[музика]
[сміх]
я
[музика]
[сміх]
хол
[музика]
R
[сміх]
[музика]
Дякую дя дяку
[оплески]
лі
треба що
[музика]
[оплески]
да тому що Тані всі це свято кого уї
але моє питання буде наступне які Викки
зараз стоять на 29й день народження
нашої держави України виклики існування
держави і на сьогоднішній день цей парад
парад ветеранів парад Незалежності парад
патріотів
хай хтось спробує заборонити Нехай хтось
розкажуть сотням тисяч людей що такі
паради не потрібно Ми впевнені в тому що
це є сила яка збереже Україну Це є сила
яка не дозволить злочинній і
некомпетентній владі переснути червоні
лінії за якими стоїть знищення держави
звищення суверенітету ліквідація і
руйнація Незалежності ліквідація
руйнації армії економіки бойового духу
культурного підгрудтя фундаменту
державності і на сьогоднішній день саме
це Подивіться на реакцію людей саме це
саме кількість людей які беруть тут
участь ції акції дає серйозні підстави
для оптимізму і є дуже тривожним
звіночком владі де жартуєте з
незалежністю незалежністю не
жертуєте члогічно коробки під назви з
незалежністю на жарту дуже багато сі я
себе тут відчуваю абсолютно природні
і як верховний гокомандуч 14-19 років і
Як лідер європейської солідарності це є
рух країни в Європу це є рух країни в
НАТО це є відповідальня тим очікуванням
які є в абсолютної більшості людей і
відповіданя тим розчаруванням яка
некомпетентна дедилетантська Зелена
Влада принесла за останні 15 міс це є
наш відповідь що ми будемо боронити і
захищати Україну останє запитання за що
Ви любите Україну якою хочете бачити
через цількиж 29 років дуже простене
слово
європейські Я впевнений в тому що саме
європейські саме членство в
НАТО саме членство в НАТО є тою
відповіддю на безпекові виклаки саме
європейською є тою відповіддю на
соціальні економічні виклаки Я впевнений
в тому що саме так і дякую
дкуюку
[музика]
[оплески]
SU
[музика]
95 та Дякуємо
вам проходьте не мокуйте крищати
Пропустіть людей на
[музика]
концерт мы можем взять выше или нет оно
ничего не изменит я
поняла і ми не розходимось ми будемо
співати гімн великою
[музика]
родиною Я краще
промовже
[музика]
Маши проїжжайте
проїжджайте Саша
іский запам'ятай цей момент
Саша момент коли ти не стримав
[музика]
слово
[сміх]
[музика]
hoy
[сміх]
[музика]
Dr
о
мпражисяба дума что сечас машина
[музика]
остановится идеале просто чтобы
подхватили они ко Я думаю сечас я отрою
микрофончик
возёш а микрофончик возёш ко
сечас всё стоим там А это че
И может как-то
заберём всё Спасибо
большое не сильно
Нор норма сильно
Ми звоні
[оплески]
українці Ми продовжуємо там ще колона
вона мусить пройти майданом а
потімши захисникі
[музика]
українижаєе
компетент
Ой Настя хорошо в кадр попала
случайно если хотят мы можем общак
сделать где-то подняться типа чуть-чуть
там подивимся я поки таки напвстм сделаю
посмотрим что в эфире и
быстрокра ще
по пішли
мабуть да есть
такое
давай Ну давай туда о
товариство ви щоно бачили Це відеоролик
машвої армії який реально надихає який
потигує який показує міць і силу
нашої
армії товарист ми
зараз традиційно пошли
куда-небудьстаже Ну
давайте
зі спільного виконання державного гівну
України не
вмерла України
ні
славані воля
[музика]
ще нам
браттялюгалю
с
напроти Ало Слава
Україні да да
на Майдані те
саме внизуі біля Стели дивись подивися
лівіше там де
міст ось і зараз секундуми навпроти
бігбена там де бачиш
такк не сходими нівалось дивись тиж ба
нініні бачуш ці чорні
колони Незалежності україмо
ні-ні Ні ми не на мосту ми не не
піднімались ми посередині між мостом дво
поседині на газоні тут так ну не на
сходах ми трошки
туті ну хай да таже на сходах о
пожежна машина
[музика]
стоїтьлада
буде буде
[музика]
приїти ОІ президенто
україли
волотерів учасників війни з
Росією адже пандемія нас не
залишаєір що ми
будемо
будемо посмо
[музика]
гарно Це ж
проходичко
ноновини да сечас почекаю
навушни А що там розказувать вони пі
президента що
вас вже заспівали гі чось і він сказав
що не наїжджає зовсім і нам ногу
привезуть але ж не при Ну як все вони
вже заспівали гімн
ага знаєте по оцьому закону про
колабораціонізм по цьому вони йтимуть до
офісу Вони не сказали просто с вони про
рифмастеро а почму поняла по як його Да
да да Юлія кузменко поім да спочатку на
пешечку а потім до частина з них йде на
європейську площу А чо чо його знаюна
мене ми звідси просто
бачилива
мене в графіці написано що на
європейсьст акція і має бути
поро да Що для тебе Порошенко подарив
серйозно та да вони всі знають то просто
Таня вона трохи не знає Ну Таня - це наш
редактор ти наш
[музика]
верхою
Так значить по
чуш так А може ти мене виставиш
отту тоже ну же класно і трохи інша
картинка але
красивоту це я в перший раз розклав ски
офігеть я бачила прямий Вони завжди
астріча на з самого
[музика]
ранку
масштаб Ну короче подумай
[музика]
сам думай
ало
погляд
[оплески]
Поло святий злянці іціли немочі наші
імені твого ради Господи помилуй Господи
помилуй Господи помилуй Слава отцю і
сину і Святому духові і нині і посякчас
і на віки віків амінь Отче наш що єси на
небесах нехай святиться ім'я твоє нехай
прийде царство твоє нехай буде воля Твоя
як на небі так і на землі Хліб наш
насущний дай нам сьогодні І прости нам
провини наші як і ми прощаємо винуватцям
нашим і не введи нас у спокусу але
визволи нас від
лукавого бо твоє є царство і сила і
слава отця і Сина і Святого Духа нині і
повсякчас і на віки
віків
амінь Господні явився нам
благословеннуте в ім'я
господ
благословляйте
Господи Благослови прийде в ім'я
господнє
благослоі'явився
на Благословен імя господ
го
госпо іяви
само Благослови ім'я
[музика]
господ бо
госпо і
з'явився благословить то в ім'я
господн Спаси Господи
[музика]
твої і Благослови
насія
твоє
перемо побожному народові нашому на
супратики
дой і Христом твоїм окороняй нас
опасе Господу
помолимо
Господи
помилуй Боже великий Боже всесильний Ми
грішні діти твої покорі сердец наших
приходимо до тебе і схиляємо голови наші
отче прости провини наші та провини
батьків дітів і пратіів наших
ми нині благаємо тебе щиру молитву нашу
і подяку нашу за безмежне милосердя твоє
до нас
вислухай наші молитви і прийми благання
сердець наших Благослови нашу
Батьківщину Україну долю та щастя їй дай
милосердний Господи усім хто вдається до
тебе з благанням лість твою пода
благаємо тебе Боже за братів і сестер
наших за воїнів затових за сирів за
коліки Неміш
лосердя допомоги твоє потребують зєднай
нас усіх в єдину велику христову сім'ю
щоб усі
людиславили величне ім'я твоє завжди
нині і повсякчас і на віки
віків
амінь вітаємо всіх з днем незалежності
Слава Україні героя
Слава Дякуємо нашим
капеланам які День і
ніч разом з нашими військовими на сході
несуть службу які в військових частинах
підтримують моральний бойовий дух наших
хлопців та дівчат а зараз слово має
п'ятий президент України Петро
Порошенко
Дякую Дякую дорогі мої Дякую за сотні
тисяч українців які сьогодні вийшли на
вулиці Києва для того щоб
продемонструвати свою шану і повагу
незалежності України бо День
Незалежності
Це неначе різд боєвокресіння
одночасно 29 років тому на уламках
імперії з'явилася Самостійна Україна і
це день Відродження день народження
нової країни але ж вона Україна повстала
не на порожньому місці
проження нашої тисячолітньої
державницької традиції яку ми з вами
відновили Господи
людей
твоїх і Благослови
насі
твоє
[музика]
перемогу побожному народові нашому на
супротивників подай і хрестом твоїм
охороняй нас
оселю
[оплески]
твою Господу
помолимось Господи
помилуй Боже великий Боже всесильний Ми
грішні діти твої у покорі сердець наших
приходимо до тебе і схиляємо голови наші
отче прости провини наші та провини
батьків дідів і прадідів наших Прими
нині благаємо тебе щиру молитву нашу і
подяку нашу за безмежне милосердя твоє
до нас вислухай наші молитви і прийми
благання сердець наших Благослови нашу
Батьківщину милістьвою подай благаємо
тебе Боже за братів і сестер наших за
воїнів за вдовить за сирі за калік і
немічник і за тих хто твого милосердя та
допомоги твоєї потребують з'єднай нас
усіх в єдину велику христову сім'ю щоб
усі люди як брати славили величне ім'я
твоє завжди нині і повсякчас і на віки
віків
амінь вітаємо всіх з днем незалежності
Слава Україні Героям
слава Дякуємо нашим капеланам які День і
ніч разом з нашими військовими на сході
несуть службу які військових частинах
підтримують моральний бойовий дух наших
хлопців та
дівчат а зараз слово має п'ятий
президент України Петро
порошенкоко
Порошенко
[оплески]
поро
вийшли на вулиці Києва для того щоб
продемонструвати свою шану і повагу
незалежності
України бо День Незалежності
Це неначе Різдво і вокресіння
одночасно 29 років тому на уламках
імперії з'явилася Самостійна Україна і
це день Відродження день народження
нової країни але ж вона Україна повстала
не на порожньому місці продовження нашої
тисячолітньої державницької традиції яку
ми з вами відновили і після майже
350 років російського панування в Москві
було точно впевнені ніби Україна навіки
розчинилася в неосяжних просто ра
імперії А вона відродилась і Хіба це не
є наше справжнє
Воскресіння як Великого європейського
народу як великої європейської нації і я
вітаю вас всіх Дорогі українці з цим
великим
[оплески]
святом своєю
волею своєю незалежноністю ми з вами не
поступимося
ніколи і дуже добре сказано в святковому
зверненні 1 грудня Україна дихає
свободою Це її кисень і святкування
річниці Незалежності
Це вшанування всіх героїв які століттями
працювали і боролися заради того щоб цей
день
настав святкування Цього дня Це
демонстрація сили і звітяги нинішнього
покоління
українців на жаль не всі це розуміють і
тому
насамперед давайте привітаємо ветеранів
війни за незалежність які захищали
країну від російської агресії і які тут
сьогодні серед
нас
дякуємо
дякуємо дякуємо
куємо ветеранам слава слава слава
ветеранам слава слава слава і це ми з
вами маємо високу честь стояти поруч з
ними і ми вклоняємося всім хто зараз в
цей час на сході України
боронить нашу землю українську і наш
український
народ я прошу вшанувати пам'ять героїв
які віддали своє життя за Україну за її
волю за честь за славу за народ в тому
числі і тих 48 воїнів полеглих з початку
нинішнього 2020 року для вшанування їх
пам'яті Оголошую хвилину на
мовчання Дякую дорогі
співвітчизники 190
році Уявіть собі Україна
успадкувала більше одного
мільйона
військовослужбовців хлопці Залиште його
бо і такий Нам
потрібен він один і це максимум найщо
спромоглася п'ята
колона і він тікає нехай
тікає Я дуже люблю вас але це вони
бояться наших зборів наших слів наших
дій і я ще раз Хочу наголосити уявить
собі в 91му році більше 800 000 була
кількість військових які прийняли
присягу на вірність народу України і з
91го по
14-й вся Влада тільки те і робила Що
звільняло особовий склад скорочувала
кількість зброї
розбазарювала і розпродавала
майно Україна її тодішнє керівництво
зрклися ядерної зброї в обмін на
пустопорожній Будапештський
меморандум дозволили тодішньому
командуванню чорноморського флота
зірвати присягу флоту на вірність народу
України а потім погодилися на його
басування в українському Севастополі
і за 23 роки вони залишили армію
голою
босою голодною і ті хто є на цьому
майдані і ті хто є на цій сцені точно
знають це бо в 14му році вони На власні
очі дивилися в якому стані ми прийняли
збройні сили і тому я наголошую справжнє
державне будівництво ми з вами воїни
волонтери добровольці
небайдужі розпочали зі створення нової
української армії і я дякую волонтерам Я
дякую добровольцям Я дякую суспільству
кожному хто перерахував тоді в 14му свої
останні
копійчини я дякую нашим міжнародним
партнерам усі разом Ми з честю виконали
це надскладне
завдання ми з вами нарешті вперше стали
незалежними від Росії у
військово-оборонному сенсі і за 5п років
інтенсивної
розбудови країна держава повернула собі
нарешті історичну пам'ять згадала і
нарешті вшанувала справжніх українських
героїв зробила вирішальні і безповоротні
кроки до відродження і захисту нашої рід
співучої української мови нашого
культурно-просвітницького гуманітарного
простору і проривом в здобутті духовної
Незалежності нарешті став томос про
автокефалію для православної церкви
[оплески]
українияємояємо
томос який Україні і українцям надав
його цесвятість Вселенський патріарх
варфоломей і
синод Вселенського патріархату і
зараз рухається по всій планеті визнання
нашої церкви православними церквами
експерти назвали це справжньою
геополітичною катастрофою для Росії Я
погоджуюсь з цією
оцінкою ще елементом рідної війни Росії
проти нас українців був безпрецедентний
економічний тиск і Блокада Москва
закрила свої ринки Москва закрила
транзит а тоді йшло більше третини
українського експорту вона хотіла
поставити нас на коліна Кремль хотів
удушити нас
економічно Путін робив це лише для того
щоб спровокувати потужну соціальну
номічну кризу в країні і ми з вами тоді
не
здалися ми не дали Кремлю такого поговор
подарунку ми
вистояли і допомогла нам в цьому угода
про асоціацію про яку я оголосив на
цьому самому місці на європейській площі
і підписав уже в першій місяць свого
президентства і це ця угода включно з
зоною вільної торгі лю дозволила
Буквально за кілька років повністю
переорієнтуватися на європейський ринок
відновити економічне зростання Ми
нарешті стали економічно і головне
енергетично незалежними від
Росії весною Минулого року наша
команда передала новообраний на й момент
владі економіку з квартальним зростанням
майже в
4,5%
це вдалося завдяки нашій спільній роботі
чіткому євроінтеграційному курсу
європейське і євроатлантична інтеграція
прагнення українського народу і
української держави вступити до
Євросоюзу - це наріжні камні нашого
державного
будівництва ми ще раз наголошую
невипадково з вами зібралися саме на цій
площі неми тільки оголосили про угоду
про асоціацію а в 13-му році саме на цю
площу люди приходили з вимогою до влади
підписати в 13-му році угоду про
асоціацію на цьому місці в 17-му році 11
червня ми з вами проголосили про
відкриття дверей Європи для українців
вступ в дію угоду про безвіз
тут
[оплески]
і я хочу ще наголосити Що на цьому місці
На цій європейській площі ми з вами
відсвяткуємо вступ України до
Європейського
Союзу Хоча я реаліст І хочу сказати ясно
що це точно станеться але станеться не
при цій владі На
[оплески]
жаль
ще і
сім і сім важко
сперечатися але я хочу нагадати ще одну
трагічну
сторінку біля цієї площі в 100 мтрах тут
на Грушевського 22 січня 14го року своє
життя за європейську Україну віддав
Білорус Михайло
жезнеєвський я як президент мав високу
честь присвоїти посмертно Михайлові
звання герой України акт про
проголошення незалежності Україна
затвердила 24 серпня 91го року а 25
серпня білоруський парламент проголосив
державну незалежність Білорусі і зараз в
ці дні ця державна незалежність під
величезною загрозою стратегічна мета
Росії
аншлюс захоплення
Білорусі Путін хоче поглинути Білорусь
так як Гітлер колись поглинув Австрію
Натомість ми українці Євросоюз а в першу
чергу і головне білоруський народ
потребує справжньої незалежної
білоруської держави і ми з вами мільйони
українців тримаємо кулаки за те щоби
демократія в Білорусі перемогла і щоби
білоруський народ і тільки він обрав
собі владу на вільних і чесних виборах і
щоби в Білорусі не пролилася кров і щоби
її землю не топтала російська
солдатня ми з вами з Європейської площі
Києва висловлюємо повну Солідарність
європейську Солідарність з білоруським
народом живе
біларусьживе
бірусь
живелорусь живелорусь
живе
вечно дорогі
однодумці серце сповнюється радістю коли
ти бачиш велолюдне море коли десятки і
десятки тисяч людей яких Зеленський
сьогодні попросив не плутатися в нього
під ногами пішли не на офіційне
Шапіто А на велелюдний марш справжніх
захисників
вітчизни тут зібралися небайдужі
люди Оплески вам
це ті
люди які в 14му і 19му
роках не давали концерти в Криму і на
окупованих
територіях не сиділи і служили в
диванних сотнях паплюжичи українське
військо і українську державу А ті хто зі
зброєю в руках захищав країну закладав
фундамент української
державності сюди прийшли всі ті хто вже
півтора роки пильнує щоби цей
державницький фундамент не міг бути
зруйнованим якби вони не старалися І
знаєте Настав час визнати фундамент
виявився
доволі міцним фундамент який ми з вами
збудували але друзі мої Це нам точно не
дає підстав
розслаблятися більше Рокі
тому
українці ми не звинуватуємо їх Вони
мають
право на це рішення бо це демократія
вони трохи збилися з
дороги зеленуваті болотні вогні люди
помилково сприйняли за зірку
дороговказ
аболотян
трисовіння іноді небезпечніше за ворожі
кулі і кожен тут присутніх Кожен з нас
чує нехай він запитає сам себе той хто
дивиться нас по телебаченню в ютбі в
соціальних мережах А чи стало за останні
16 місяців наша держава
сильнішою А чи сильнішою зброєю стали
бійці які стримують російську навалу на
сході а чи задоволені ці бійці
відведенням з позицій за які заплачено
кров'ю
побратимів А чи вірять вони що агресора
можна подолати просто переставши
стріляти А чи впевненіше себе почуває
українська дипломатія адже Все частіше
прокра в світі говорять без України чого
не було за наших часів А чи сильнішою
стала
економіка 16 місяців тому вірус
некомпетентності вірус
ділітантства вірус
безвідповідальності вразив
Україну ми з вами не тішили себе
ілюзіями але десь в глибині душі В
тривозі за майбутнє країни все ж таки
припускали а може вони засвоять ну
принаймні найпростіші
уроки ази державного
управління
може папуга навчиться говорити А може
відміть навчитьсяся їздити на
мотоциклі На жаль Влада нічому не
навчилася експеримент з новими обличчями
провалився але ж друзі мої не залежністю
не
жартують а президент це не роль в
виставі а важкі хрести і відповідальна
робота управління країною не вечір
гумору Влада інтелектуально і
організаційно не здатна вирішувати ті
проблеми які зараз стоять перед країною
ми ж з вами робимо Все від нас залежне
щоби мінімізувати шкоду якої ділітантура
комедіантів завдає
України і якщо не відбулося найгіршого
то лише завдяки активній вашій позиції
ветеранів волонтерів небайдужих активної
частині українського суспільства
політикамдержавникам Минулого року
червоні лінії на креслені десятками
тисяч українських патріотів застерегли
владу від
капітуляції в парламенті європейська
Солідарність за підтримки громадянського
суспільства змогла торпедувати безліч
безглузних ініціатив мо на більшості
європейська Солідарність - Це є
українська опозиційна сила здатна
захищати громадян України від влади
ділетантів уособленою команду
Зеленського рівно як і від реваншистів
п'ятої колони згуртованих вопа
[оплески]
зж і ви скажете що опозиційна платформа
- це теж опозиція Так але не українська
це російська опозиція до української
державності це російська опозиція до
самого факту
Української держави як соборної
незалежної як європейської держави яка
має європейську євроатлантичну
перспективу і
націленість цієї російської п'ятої
колони на завоювання місцевих рад в
південних і східних областях створює
додаткову небезпеку додаткову загрозу
територіальної цілісності України Влада
ж це не вигласи і корупціонери
патологічно не здатні керувати країною
вони розвалили управління державою і
вони несуть таку ж загрозу розвалу для
місцевого
самоврядування в Україні настане певний
колапс якщо не
підстрахуватися професіоналами і
патріотами які мають об'єднатися навколо
нашої команди і видно що досвідчені
управлінці на місцях мають мінімізувати
ту шкоду яку завдають дилетанти з
зеленої команди місцеві вибори які
одночасно пройдуть по всій країні є
вагомою політичною подією від результата
цієї загальнонаціональної компанії
залежить Повірте не лише справжність
місцевої
каналізації чи якість сільської дороги
але й доля країни в цілому
заборона її
федералізації і місцеві вибори мають
стати потужним корабельним ривуном
сигналом Який дасть зрозуміти слугам що
трумфальное шествие зелной власті
завершилося зелень падає Восени ми
знаємо це
точно
порошеко
Порошенко
Порошенко але дуже дякую але дуже
важливо усвідомити щоби запобігти
поступовому і часом дуже малопомітному
для широкого загалу сповзанню України
назад в сферу російського впливу
потрібні Єдність і координація зусиль
державницьких політичних сил так як
сьогодні це відбулося під час нашого з
вами параду ветеранів Ми всі були тут
об'єднані я дякую всім хто взяв участь
всім хто це підтримав так діяти і в
наступному і в
майбутньому
хоча На жаль я можу сказати що ця наша
ініціатива чомусь в штики була
зустрінута окремими
політиканами Вона ця
протидія знаходить підтримку на
проросійських
каналах і я точно думаю що нашою єдністю
і згрунтованістю ми це подолаємо ми
знайдемо головне підтримку в
українському суспільстві розуміння в
українській громадськості Дорогі
українці вже за рік нашій з вамі
фантастичній найкращій в світі державі
виповниться 30 років це рік певної
зрілості вік усвідомлення власних
можливостей вік потенціалу власної мети
безумовно аналіз власних помилок країна
вчиться ще краще розуміти різницю між
правдою і кремльовськими фейками і
брехнею які годували нас 16 місяців тому
І продовжують годувати зараз між
відповідальною політикою і популізмом
українське суспільство все краще бачить
ціну солодким але нереалістичним
обіцянкам а усвідомлення прораху
під впливом фейків і емоцій зроблене в
19 році станеть нарешті ефективним
щепленням для України на майбутнє Бо
Україна сильна Вона має дуже потужний
запас міцності щоби вистоїти супроти
ворогів як ми з вами це продемонстрували
в 14му році і щоб придбати імунітет який
захистить від випадкових людей яких
Іронія долі підняла до вершин влади
ми твердо наголошуємо Україна буде
європейською державою Україна є
європейською державою Україна буде
членом Європейського Союзу і Україна
буде членом
НАТО і цю стратегію підтримує більшість
українців А ще є активна Але пасіонарна
меншість яка не просто підтримує а
здатна приму будь-яку владу рухатися
саме в цьому геополітичному напрямку без
жодних викрутасів без жодних Какая
разница і я раз вже можу знову згадати
про армію скажу і про порад
розумію ну при всій повазі чи не повазі
що біля вагону
сердючці йому комфортніше ніж біля
танку
Я нічого проти не маю але просто там
Йому не так
лячно ну ви зрозуміли про кого я
так він не
розуміє На жаль Я шкодую Про це він не
розуміє значення параду для
військових він не розуміє значення
параду для справжніх
українців він не розуміє значення параду
для нашого суспільства і врешті решт
можливість влади відзвітувати за рік а
що ж зроблено для армії це у випадку що
якщо є чим звітувати нам було бо сильні
сильні ми не тільки бронею але й нашим
потужним духом Перемоги який ми
демонстрували і будемо продовжувати
демонструвати Моя порада для нього не
називаючи
ім'я досить бояться армії
досить ховатися від неї за
кордоном досить приховано зневажати її
досить ухилятися від обов'язків
Верховного
головнокомандувача усех бомбить не
треба Але Моя порада наступного року в
день 30ї річниці Незалежності найкращї в
світі держави
Україна на
Хрещатику має бути великий військовий
справжній
парад з технікою з
авіацією з найкращими в світі воїнами з
ветеранами з
добровольцями я не беру на себе
обов'язок що вони його проведуть але я
наголошую не зробить це влада зробимо ми
з вами
саме ми
вміємо ми придумаємо як її
примусити бо дехто в армії не служив а в
армії кажуть не можеш навчимо не
хочеш
правильно і попри наміри зовнішніх
ворогів про по слабкодухість внутрішніх
зрадників з п'ятої
колони попре критуче невигластво та
безпросвітний дилетантизм теперішньої
влади я хочу вас запевнити дорогі
українці бачачи вас і дивлячись вам в
очі Все в нас точно буде
добре і слава
Україні
слава
пороко
Порошенко
[оплески]
поро ге
гегеге Іван Леньо ваші
опласки я від імені усієї України Дякую
нашим захисникам за мирне небо над нашою
країною під час виконання Іваном пісні
мульфар ви бачили на екранах
фотографії наших новітніх героїв
небесного легіону небесної когорти
нашої вони живі поки ми про них
пам'ятаємо чи не
так і ми нікому не дамо сплюндрувати
пам'ять про наших загиблих військових це
є наш святий обов'язок так
[оплески]
Україно І зараз я до слова запрошую
одного з багатьох які в повні які в
повні відчув біль втрати в боротьбі за
незалежність
України Сергій
[оплески]
журовель Слава
Україні Дорогі
українці моя родина вітає вас всіх з
днем
незалежності
відстань від Дніпропетровщини до Києва
так
от 400 км коли сюди
їдеш Так у нас в селах построєно і в
містах що обов'язково над дорогою стоять
сцвинтері І от їдеш І бачиш Отакі
прапори
прапори остались на землі а тіла
журавлів і Соколів полетіла в
небо на Ралик нашої сім'ї пішов від нас
пішов не просто він боровся за своє
життя він боровся за
Україну ну Влада зробила
так що коли
миї жінки ярославкині бабушки сказали
бережіть серце А вона каже в мене серця
нема там камінь як же можеть в матері
буть серце коли їй поставили вибор
вибирати день смерті з 1 по
16 яка це мати витерпить вчора так наша
родина
вибрала вчора було 40
днів як душа нашого сина полетіла до
Господа
Бога він буде одним із тих Соколів чи
журавлів
які з нами но не
поряд я вам скажу одне отам немає
політичних партій Повірте мені там есть
Легіон есть визволителі есть Борці в
яких одна єдина ціль наша вільна
незалежна любима кохана
Україна чому ж ми отут ходячи по цій
землі оббиваємо один одному руки і плечі
а не може просто взятися за руки
об'єднатися і зробити одну єдину квітучу
Україну щоб оці діти не плакали а раділи
тому як ми живемо Слава Україні геро
Слава загиблим Героям російською
російсько-української війни тричі слава
слава
слава загиблим Героям
російсько-української війни тричі слава
слава слава
і у нас сьогодні було присвоєно декілька
високих звань героїв
України
артистам іншим я їх не
обговорюю але він не
почув заклику мільйонів
українців підписати указ і присвоювати
Ярославу
журавлю звання героя України бо немає
тіх хто зас жи в цього звання
більше і я прошу щоби десятки тисяч
людей які сьогодні були в цьому марші
ветеранів які зібралися тут які
дивляться нас знову черговий раз
Звернулися до влади з вимогою
негайно присвойте
журавлю звання героя це не йому потрібно
це потрібно Україні і українцям і нехай
він про це чує і нехай ба батько знає як
ми будемо цього вимагати Це точно буде
Дякую Слава Україні і слава
[оплески]
героям сьогодні товариство 24 серпня
День незалежності
і для кожного нормального нормального
українця цей день має починатися з
військового параду на
Хрещатику це ж логічно
так
логічно так було в
2014 році і так було 5ть років поспіль
після
14-го вже два роки ми не маємо змоги
насолоджуватись проходженням нашої армії
проїздом нашої техніки по головній
вулиці країни але ми пам'ятаємо і знаємо
як це повинно бути товариство увага на
[оплески]
екрани
[музика]
[оплески]
Слава
[музика]
Україні
Слава
[музика]
[оплески]
Україні
[музика]
[оплески]
ви собі Пригадали який був наш останній
справжній військовий парад Ми бачили
нашу армію Ми бачили наших наших героїв
нашу силу нашу
потугу
сьогодні наша армія опинилась в тому
становищі коли треба воювати в тому
стані воїна який воює зі зв'язаними
руками зі зв'язаними ногами і
зав'язаними
очима сьогодні український солдат він
фактично бачить явного ворога перед
собою і чує ворожу риторику чергової
консерви для якої Ну не все так
однозначно не всё так однозначно для них
завжди було не всё так однозначно ми
бачимо нечувану атаку на армію збоку
п'ятої колони ми бачимо ми бачимо як
підняли голови всі ті для кого Майдан
став особистою трагедією а семирічний
опір прикрою
несподіванкою Вони ж бо планували як за
два тижні нас змести захопити вони вже
собі наштампували медальк за взяття
Києва за взяття Львова Вінниці
івано-франківська запобеждения
бандеровской властиі а не получилось не
вийшло наша армія для них як кістка в
горлі за президента Порошенка оці падли
вони боялися підняти голови вони боялися
подати свій голос і вони тіснилися по
темних кутках і ховалися за анонімними
акаунтами в
соцмережах зараз їм здається що Україна
ослабла що Ані Зеленський Ані його Уряд
не стануть битися за Україну так як
билися
попередники вони бачать як офіційна
Україна боїться зачепити чи образити не
дай боже агресора який іде на на зустріч
найбільш абсурдним і знущальним вимогам
вони радіють коли знову порушуються
питання про проведення фейкових виборів
на тимчасово окупованих територіях вони
хочуть нав'язати нам ці Квазі республіки
зі своїми правилами вони хочуть щоб ми
грали за їхніми правилами сьогодні Вони
думають що настав час реваншу але
так не буде так не буде тому що це
говорить Україна
Так я не
[оплески]
чую
сьогодні українці Які 6сть років тому
вони здатні відрізнити зерно від
полови Вони знають де правда а де брехня
Вони знають що святе а що грішне
сьогодні ми товариство об'єднуємо
навколо себе ветеранів
військовослужбовців ветеранів нової
української армії ветеранів спецслужб та
добровольчих батальйонів щоб протистояти
оцьому повзучому реваншу який як гадина
не зупиняється І ми готові протистояти
здачі національних інтересів ми
відстоїмо Україну та
так сьогодні ми єднаємо тих хто зупинив
агресора в 14му році і до сьогоднішнього
дня протистоїть йому на сході і
протистоїть тут всередині України
внутрішньому ворогу так званій п'ятій
колоні і ми знаємо хто стане плечем до
плеча Серце до
серця і агресор Я впевнений що він об
нас обламає зуби і я знаю що
Донбас тимчасово окуповані території
вони знову знову будуть
Україною Росія все почала з Донбасу там
все і закінчиться Росія об нас зламає
свої гнилі зуби і зараз я до слова
запрошую героя України генераллейтенанта
Збройних Сил України народного депутата
України зустрічайте Михайло
[оплески]
Забродський
Дякую Дуже хотілось би почати з вітань з
нашим національним святом Але ми всі
добре знаємо що сьомий рік поспіль не з
нашої вини але це свято має
чіткий присмак пороху і
крові боротьба триває і наразі зараз час
вести мову саме
проєднання нас тут присутніх декілька
десятків тисяч ми всі різні за віком
статтю родом поточних занять але всі ми
горді і волелюбні люди
більшість з нас добре знає що таке страх
але не
боязнь Хай боїться кремлівський
тиран А ми з вами звикли розраховувати
на вірну руку і добру волю товаришів по
зброї Особисто я з припрезирством
ставлюсь до спроб Москви псевдореспублік
будь-якої країни фізично або гібридно
зазіхати на мою
вітчизну
і в ніякому разі не можна припустити щоб
ці спроби були
успішними дуже складно зрозуміти те що
зараз небезпека кроється трохи в іншому
На жаль
безвідповідальна капітулянтська полі
політика діючої влади здатна одним
розщркам пера будь то в Мінську або в
Парижі креслити все що булоро зроблено
за останні сть
років і подвійно прикро що це роблять
люди які початку Незалежності мріяли
спочатку про відновлення імперії А зараз
їхні послідовники майстри гібридного
впливу не в результаті фронтових успіхів
а в результаті професійною виборчої
шулярської афери захоплюють всі владні
структури
Наша
історія жертви останніх років закликають
нас до того щоб ми в черговий раз
вичистили ці авгівіставні і припинили
той безлад який коїться в
країні в цій складній обстановці рішення
може бути лише одне це єднання єднання
людей в першу чергу які пройшли горнило
війни які свого часу а або виконуючи
професійний обов'язок або за покликом
серця залишали наприклад затишний
Київський офіс і міняли його на окопи
десь під Зайцева а саме головне - це
люди які протягом всього цього часу
втрачали друзів і братів ризикували
життям і
здоров'ям священний принцип демократії
про те що більшість завжди права завжди
потрібно декларувати
з великою поправкою Так але більшість
має бути розумною
розважливою і
справедливою ми ведемо мову про
об'єднання яке ставить своєю метою не
боротьбу за пільги і їх реалізацію ми
ведемо мову про
об'єднання яке має брати активну участь
в політичному житті
країни це заклик до нового формату
суспільних відносин там де
стійкість і
порядність є основою свободи і самого
життя ми всі представники різних
політичних сил і різних рухів більшость
з нас пройшли складний бойовий і
політичний шлях ті ідеологічні дискусії
які ми ведемо вони можуть вразити людину
яка не звикла Ду
висловлюватись або писати вільно Дехто з
нас оцінюють обстановку більш критично і
навіть готові довести до розколу або
наблизитись до цієї небезпечної межі але
різниця в думках ні в коєму разі не
означає різницю в принципах ми можемо
по-різному називати наших братів і
сестер наших соратників по боротьбі але
всіх нас об'єднує один принцип Ми
українці Ми
патріоти в основу об'єднання планується
покласти п'ять основних
засад
Україна її незалежність і територіальна
цілісність це не товар для політичного
торгу правда за яку ми стоїмо має
спиратися на силу і ми готові
діяти наше майбутнє і майбутнє нації ше
в сімї європейських
народів в нашому серці не має бути
нерішучості або
страху кінцем нашої боротьби може бути
лише
перемога всі п'ять
принципів секредо нашої політичної віри
це основа для майбутньої роботи це
наріжний
камінь за яким До речі будуть
оцінюватись робота і служба тих кому ми
дамо велику честь бути нашими
лідерами Дозвольте закінчити словами
Гетьмана байдана Зіновія
Хмельницького які
він призніс в промові на знаменитій
Чорній раді в
1654 році
А хто з нами не згоден тому на чотири
сторони вільна дорога Слава
Україні
Слава товариство шановне ім'я наступного
нашого спікера викликає жах у ворогів А
візиткою можна проводити вигнання
диявола зустрічайте Дмитро
Ярош
дякую дякую
друзі Я хочу привітати вас від імені
бійців і командирів української
добровольчої армії які і зараз на
східному фронті російсько-української
війни боронять незалежність і
територіальну цілісність нашої держави
наші хлопці сьмий рік ведуть боротьбу з
тою російською агресію яку вони
розпочали в
14-му ми знаємо що можемо
досягнути поставлених завдань перемогти
ворога тільки тоді коли ми єдині коли
єдині збройні сили коли єдині
представники Нацгвардії добровольчих
формувань служби безпеки України інших
силових структур ми знаємо що ми можемо
перемогти в боротьбі за Україну коли
будуть єдині в тилу єдині державницькі
партії громадські організації та рухи
ветеранський рух коли будуть єдині Брати
по зброї яких не будуть розшаркувати і
купувати ті хто сидить зараз у владних
коридорах Ми прекрасно знаємо що ті
покидьки які зараз пробують зробити
Реванш прикладають максимум
зусиль але їм нічого не вдасться ця
наволоч буде на своєму місці Ми не
панькали з ворогом на війні не
панькаємось зараз ми не будемо з ними
толерантно поводити себе тут в тилу
безумовно же наша сила в єдності
перемога Буде за нами Слава
Україні наш наступний промовець не лише
зумів домогтися ухвалення Закону України
Про забезпечення функціонування
української мови як державної але і
зараз спільно з побратимами відстоює
непорушність цього
закону зустрічайте народний депутат
України спікер парламенту минулого
скликання Андрій
[оплески]
Парубій Слава Україні Героям слава Слава
Україні ероям Слава Слава
Україні Слава Я хочу привітати усіх з
великим святом днем незалежності
особливо наших волонтерів і воїнів які
боронили боронять сьогодні нашу
незалежність і для мене за особливу
честь вітати усіх з Днем Незалежності
тут сьогодні на майдані на європейській
площі біля Українського дому в нас
зібралось десятки тисяч сьогодні щоб
шанувати цей день і я пригадав як тут на
майдані на цій площі ми збиралися у
великі дні наших змагань як ми збирали
тут в 90-х роках коли боролись За
українську державність і Дмитро був тоді
теж поруч Ми стояли тут Ми стояли тут
під час помаранчевої революції Ми стояли
тут під час мовного Майдану коли
боролись За українську мову і Ми стояли
тут під час Революції
гідності тут на цьому Майдані
вирішувалась доля України Ми збирались і
тоді коли було свято і тоді коли в
нашому серці була тривога і сьогодні в
наших серцях велика тривога і ми повинні
це відверто говорити Коли ми чуємо як
Зеленський робить усе можливе і
неможливе щоб домовитись з Путіном ми
розуміємо це велика небезпека бо кожен
притомний українець розуміє ким є Путін
для України він є ворогом і ніким іншим
і коли Зеленський говорить що бачив в
його очах мир я хочу сказати це велика
брехня і вигадка пане Зеленський в очах
Путіна смерть і ненависть до України і
Це знає кожен хто був на фронті і воював
за Українську
[оплески]
Державу тут європейської площі Багато
наших добровольців парчими пішли на
фронт і вони знають і розуміють як
розуміє вся наша команда європейської
солідарності що Путін розуміє тільки
мову сили тільки мову великої
української сили і наше завдання
Сьогодні продемонструвати цю силу бо на
жаль політичне керівництво держави
сьогодні неспроможне і не здатне це
зробити вони хочуть тільки домовитись і
зараз в ці дні внесена постанова в
Верховну Раду України щоб дозволити
вибори на окупованих територіях ми
стверджували і
стверджували жодних виборів не може бути
поки не будуть виведені російські
війська поки українські прикордонники і
армія не відновить контроль на
українському кордоні І поки не будуть
роззброєні і засуджені всі бойовики але
Зеленський сьогодні який обіцяв нові
обличчя витягує комуністичний нафталін
Кравчука Фокіна колишню комуністичну
номенклатуру і посилає їх на переговори
не українських патріотів не українських
воїнів а власне тих хто будував
радянську імперію Ми сьогодні тут щоб
сказати ніхто не зможе поставити на
коліна українців ніхто не зможе
поставити на коліна Україну і їхні усі
намагання
капітуляції їхні намагання знищити
українську мову не будуть мати будь-яких
перспектив бо сотні тисяч мільйони
українців піднімуться на боротьбу за
Україну в 90-му році ми знищили
величезну радянську імперію яка
здавалась була такою потужною що весь
світ перед нею тлязся Ми стояли тут на
помаранчевій революції і ми домоглися
пороски Янукович
Ми стояли тут на мовному майдані і ми
домоглися прийняття закону про мову Ми
стояли тут на революції гідності і ми
перемогли Путіна і зараз я хочу від всіх
українців сказати
зеленському Не домовляйся з Путіном це
ворог Він розуміє тільки мову сили А
якщо ти підеш шляхом капітуляції Вся
Україна буде на майдані і не дозволить
нікому це зробити Янукович був трішки
страшніший ніж Зеленський і Радянський
союз був трішки потужніший як Зеленський
але вони не встояли перед силою
українського духу перед силою
української нації і тому сьогодні тут ми
для того щоб сказати Україну неможливо
поставити на коліна Україна переможе
Сьогодні ми маємо всі об'єднатись стати
плече до плеча і європейська
Солідарність закликає усі українські
сили плеча до плеча стати в боротьбі за
Україну Слава Україні Слава Слава
Україні Слава Слава Україні
Слава
товариство цю жінку яка зараз вийде до
мікрофона боїться шостий президент
України одним своїм словом вона зробила
з нього
потерпевшого хоча насправді вона не
сказала нічого страшного Вона просто
нагадала
про відповідальність за зраду
національних інтересів до слова
Запрошуємо народного депутата України
грозу потерпевшого
Зеленського Софію
[оплески]
федину не нарікайте на
Вкраїну вона ще ж дуже
молода їй готували домовину червона
Північна Орда
її труїли плюндрували у серце цілились
здаля їй просто жити не давали
родюча жвабила
земля криваві війни голод лютий
безжально нищили
її
чужинцям цілі досягнути допомагали ще й
свої недолютки оті погані що гірше Каїна
були святині нищили і храми і братню
кров щодня
пили тепер
Скажіть чим винна мати
що народила
яничар що може всіх нас
об'єднати і врятувати нас свічвар
лишень
любов лишень піння і плідна праця на
землі коли ж прийде до нас
прозріння
відійдуть згинуть сили злі А якщо ще
додати доброго
тлумака то все разом буде дуже добрим
рецептом як боронити незалежність нашої
держави і тому сьогодні я думаю час не
не просто
збиратися А чітко формувати плани про
детальні плани на сьогодні тут мій
колега Ігор
скаже А я скажу
Так
перше якщо хтось хоче
всдіти на своєму стільці І не гикнутися
до
завтра Наші герої мають бути
героями їх не має право ніхто помикати і
так Ярослав
має бути офіційним Героєм
України і я цього хочу саме тому тому що
це буде також взяття потерпілим на себе
відповідальності за чотирьохденні
знущання і тортури потерпілий чи
верховний головнокомандувач
чи президент України має відповідати за
кожен крок і за кожну дію
яку він бере під особистий контроль і ми
можливо
промовчимо на деякі речі якщо буде
виконаний цей святий
обов'язок
друге
політвязні яких переслідують тільки за
те що вони ветерани військові
волонтери за те що вони мають позицію і
власну
думку вони не мають діти бездоказано по
тюрмах СІЗО і ТТ і ця справа шеремети
яка зараз і далі триває і наші побратими
які зараз і далі під слідством В закриті
це є особиста знову відповідальність
Верховного
потерпілого мені кажуть я маю говорити
більше як державник можливо не згадувати
про
потерпілість але я скажу
потерпілий який боїться своєї армії який
боїться своїх волонтерів і українського
народу він не може керувати
Україною бо для України має бути
справжній лідер який поведе за собою
який буде в перших рядах який буде
боронити рідну
землю на рівні з усіма
захисниками
третє сьогодні
річниця нашої
незалежност це не є незалежність
Зеленського це не є незалежність слуг це
не є незалежність будь-якої іншої партії
яка намагається десь там керувати зараз
процесами в Україні це не є незалежність
тих хто знищує українську державність
незалежні
украї належить кожному
українцю кожному громадянину
України і нам не заборониш тримати
оборону нам не заборониш тримати
оборону нам не заборониш тримати оборону
і ми свою
незалежність будемо боронити Ні не до
кінця
ми її будемо боронити до Великої
української
Перемоги І що ми можемо зробити щоби всі
ці речі
відбулися
нарешті перестати сваритися між собою на
жаль і сьогодні рік після початку того
хаосу Ми шукаємо проблеми одне в одному
але ворогу про його проблеми його
недоліки забувай
сказати ворог постійно закидає А той не
такий А той не так Подивився а той не в
такій партії А той не такий патріот а в
результаті ми боремося між собою а ворог
виграє тому друзі усі персональні
амбіції в сторону усі образи в сторону
усі якісь недомовки особливо зараз в
сторону і ми маємо бути Єдині бо ворог в
нас є і внутрішній і зовнішній і тільки
нашою єдністю і нашою силою нашою
цільністю і
непохитністю ми можемо вибороти ту
державу ту Україну в якій ми хочемо жити
а
сьогодні я просто Дякую кожному із вас а
сьогодні от мене запиталися за що треба
любити
Україну дурне питання Україну Просто
люблять вона моя Україна вона наша
Україна найкраща в світі ріднесенька з
днем
народження слава Україні
слава Слава нації
смер Україна повнас а героям України
тричі слава слава
слава
[оплески]
запрошую до слова народного депутата
України вомого скликання учасника
російсько-української війни
співкоординатора руху опору капітуляції
Ігоря
лапіна Слава
україніла Я кожного разу виходячи маючи
честь виступати на трибуні я завжди кажу
що тут зібрались дійсно громадяни тут
немає населениня тут лише громадяни і з
такими громадянами ми побудуємо наше
громадянське суспільство але
користуючись
нагодою я хочу сказати всім Дивіться
якщо Гетьман не поважає своє військо то
військо пройдеться сьогодні без нього
сьогоднішній гетьман зневажає нас і я не
можу його ввазати гетьманом навіть попри
те що в нього сьогодні в руках булава це
тимчасово тому мене питали з щоого
будемо робити після
маршу скажу для тих хто має час і
натхнення є така можливість Ми сьогодні
оголошуємо нічну варту Правди біля
Генеральної Прокуратури України тому що
політичні переслідування які вони чинять
сьогодні на всіх хто раніше були при
владі на всіх патріотів України і на
п'ятого президента і Федина наша
побратим Я ще раз наголошую Я можливо
сьогодні Кажу занадто емоційно горло
зірвав кричачи хто такий Путін і хто
такий Зеленський Але тим не менше Я хочу
всім нагадати що ми є єдині Ми
переможемо червоні лінії малював не
Лапін чермонні лінії намалювало
громадянське суспільство і п'ята колона
і реваншисти через засоби масової
інформації вони вже довели до сказу отих
73% на сьогоднішній день 73% - це тут в
них вже їх нема Я хочу щоб всі зрозуміли
що ми можемо перемогти але лише тоді
коли ми всі разом Сьогодні є заклики
громадянського суспільства до всіх
політичних сил підписати меморандум
єдності ми лише разом можемо плече до
плеча Як казав комендант Майдану здобути
цю перемогу ви знаєте В мене сьогодні
було як то дежав'ю я чую голос парубія з
трибуни я бачу хлопці з бафами
самооборони ви знаєте Ну десь Воно таке
нагадування є і я знаю точно що ми
переможемо Слава
Україні Слава
Нації Україна
пос Україна понад усе Україна понад усе
рейтинги ніщо Україна понад
усе товариство шановні брати і сестри
вороги знаю цього чоловіка як кривавого
пастора і здригаються при згадці його
імені і починають затинатися лютим
затинанням А ми знаємо і шануємо його як
невтомного патріота України як видатного
стратега як державника як людину
сталевої волі та неймовірної
працездатності зустрічайте Олександр
туршинов
українці
патріоти брати і сестри Вітаю вас з
головним державним святом днем
незалежності України слава
Україні слава Історія вчить нас що
незалежність не можна
подарувати її не можна отримувати спадок
її не можна купити чи
запозичити не незалежність можна тільки
виборювати і її необхідно
захищати цьому вчить нас Україна
це те що болью і кров'ю написана на
наших
серцях жарти з
незалежністю погано
закінчуються вони
закінчуються
трагедією і сього
сгодні тут центром
Києва сьогодні
хрещатикам пройшли справжні
патріоти справжні
українці військові і
цивільні які показали всій країні всьому
світу
українці як і в 14му році Так і зараз
здатні захистити свою
країну друзі
чинна
влада яка другий рік поспіль боїться
провести в центрі Києва військовий
парад сьогодні зперляку обходило
хрещаток вони не розуміють що таке
незалеж для
українців тому що коли незалежність
виборювалась на
майданах коли вона захищалось на
фронті вони
жартували на фуршетах і банкетах на
лірахічних
корпоративах
коли вмирали
українці вони вибачались
перелякано
вибачались
вбивці і і нахабним
тираном який є псом
Путіна
друзі Невже вони зараз думають що
зможуть падіння свого
авторитета своєї
підтримки народу якого вони просто
обдурили від цього
захиститись політичними
репресіями обмеженням свободи
слова кишеньковими слідчими і
прокурорами продажними
суддями тиражуванням
фейкових
справ
друзі Хіба вони можуть нас цим
перелякати ні І ми сьогодні показали це
Україні показали це всьому світу але
маршами і мітингами не можна захистити
незалежність для того щоб її захистити
Ми
повинні
мобілізувати всіх
патріотів всіх справжніх
українців громадські політичні рухи для
яких Україна понад усе і об'єднавшись
наколо України переступив
свої корпоративні вузкополітичні
інтереси Ми повинні потужним маршем
змити цей зелений бруд з нашої України
[оплески]
Так саме тому європейська Солідарність
одна із перших підтримала
ініціативу провідних авторитетних Грома
діячів які звернулись до всіх політичних
сил з
проханням
зупинити будь-які конфлікти коли ти
патріот коли ти українець зупинити
протистояння між собою а посилити ряди
для протистояння зрадою із агресивною
політикою Росії саме тому ми підтримуємо
цей меморандум єдності українських сил і
звертаємось до всіх кому не байдужа
Україна
єднаємось тому що в єдності наша сила
вєднаємось Тому що це є шлях до нашої
Перемоги Слава Україні Слава патріотам
Слава вам
ті хто І сьогодні і завтра буде стояти в
проломі за нашу рідну Україну Слава
Україні
Слава ви знаєте товариство в мене
склалось Таке враження що під час
промови пана Турчинова почнуть бити
громи і
блискавиці
чесно Ми
сьогодні чули наших поважних шановних
спікерів ми сьогодні зібралися разом нас
не злякав дощ нас не злякав оцей холод
ми зібралися тому що сьогодні є наше
свято українське свято День
Незалежності коли ми один одного вітаємо
Коли ми один одному посміхаємось коли
їдеш в метро і бачиш людину в вишиванці
чи в військовій формі і ти точно
розумієш що ця людина іде на парад і так
буде кожного року Як казав пан Порошенко
що ми наступного року ми доможимось того
щоб відбувся повноцінний парад ми все
зробимо для того і Ми знов зберемося
таким велелюдним майданом ми знову
зберемося такою велелюдною ходою і ми
будемо радіти за наше військо яке буде
перед нами проходити і показувати свою
силу міць і відвагу так
так Що ж на цьому офіційна наша частина
може вважатися завершеною але це ще не
кінець нашого Заходу Я принагідно
зауважу нас ще попереду чекає Дуже
класний концерт наших шикарних драйвових
українських
гуртів шматочок концерту ви вже чули то
я був зі своїми музикантами так
інформація прозвучала на правах реклами
А ще зараз буде два класних гурти але
про них трошки пізніше А зараз як
належить по завершенню офіційної частини
я вас запрошую до спільного виконання
державного гімну України
Ще не
вмерла України
ні
слава ні
воля Ще нам
браття
українці
усміхне
[музика]
доля
Згинуть наші
воріженьки як
роса на
сонці запанує
міми
браття у
своїй
сторонці Ду ш
тіло ми
положим за нашу
свободу І
покажем що ми
браття
козацького
[музика]
роду душу й
тіло ми Поло Божим за нашу
[музика]
свободу І
покажем що ми
браття
козаського
[музика]
роду Слава Україні г слава Слава
нації
друзі вітаємо всіх вас з вами Пітер
залмай
лейло і
покажем що ми
браття
козаського
роду Слава Україні герою слава Слава
нації
[музика]
друзі вітаємо
всіх в ефірі 21 серпня Як бачите Матвій
юрівич
ганопольський